BEGIN OUR SESSION TODAY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD COUNTY
AT ALL CHANGE DALY DODD THERE
ARE ALSO. GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG HILL
WITH SO TADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
MORE LOCK MERRELL. NIELSEN PAN
TINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN
STONE NUMBER Y. CASKEY WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUEST BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN AFTER WHICH WE WILL
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR LEYVA. LET US BE
CENTERED AGAIN IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. AND TONI MORRISON'S
NINETEEN NINETY THREE NOBEL
PRIZE LECTURE. THE YOUNG
CHARACTERS IN HER NARRATION SAY.
DON'T TELL US WHAT TO BELIEVE
WHAT TO FEAR. SHOW US BELIEVE
SWIPE SKIRTS AND THE STITCH
THAT'S UNRAVELS FEARS CALL SEE
A U. L. SHOW US BELIEVES WIDE
SKIRTS AND THE STITCH THAT
UNRAVELS FEARS COAL. GOD OF ALL
CREATIVITY. AS WE SEEK THE
THREAD TO UNRAVEL THE CAUSES OF
OUR FEARS AND WHO TRUTH MAY WE
APPRECIATE THE ABUNDANCE OF
RESOURCES THAT OUR EARTH
PROVIDES FOR ALL. HEY WE WORK
TO RELEASE THE CREATIVITY OF
ALL PEOPLE FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
THROUGH JUST TO LAWS. AND THE
POWER OF OUR LANGUAGE TO
LIBERATE RATHER THAN PRESS. AND
MAY WE TRUST YOUR SPIRITS AT
WORK TO INSPIRE GUIDES AND
BRING FORTH A NEW CREATION AND
EACH ONE OF US. WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME AMEN. DILIGENCE TO
THE FLAG. GOOD FOR HER. FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY TO YEAH. MOVING ON TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR PAN ARE YOU READY. NO
PASS PASS WILL PASS THAT
TEMPORARILY. MOVING ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THERE
ARE FOUR AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK
THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO NINETY
NINE WILL BE RETURNED TO THE
ASSEMBLY. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR AUGUST
NINETEENTH THROUGH THE TWENTY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLERK. OKAY.
OTHER MODE RED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATOR ROBB. THANK ARE PRESENT
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHT SEVEN AB ONE SEVEN SIX TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. SO ORDERED.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM TO FORTY NINE A. B. SIXTY
FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. SO
ORDERED THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SEEING
NONE. WE'RE READY TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL. THREE NINETY ONE SIX
FORTY FIVE SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FI EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SENATOR WELK.
FIRST FILE ITEM THIRTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF COMMITTEE CO
BURDEN FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO
THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD MS
BURTON HAS SERVED ON THE BOARD
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
AND SHE IS THE DIRECTOR OF
CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES TEAM
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES HI BILL. GORGEOUS. HI
BRADFORD AYE KALLIO HI I CHIANG.
I DALY I DODD. DORADO GALGIANI.
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG. HI AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. BY TADO HI JACKSON I
JONES. LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. MONEY I'M MORE LOCK
MORRELL I NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER. HI STERN AYE STONE HI
NUMBER I WHAT COUNTY I WINNER
BY WILK. HI. SENATOR CENTER
WILK MOVES THE CALL WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SENATOR WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION A JONATHAN SERVICE
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BORDER REGIONS. MR SERVICE IS
CO PRESIDENT AT UNITED TALENT
AGENCY AND PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE UCLA JOHNSON
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER CENTER HE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES I BILL. I PURCHASED I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO HI I CHIANG
I DALY BY DOT ARE THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE
HUESO. BY TITLE I JACKSON AYE
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. MONNING HI MORE LOCK.
MORALE NO NIELSEN HI PAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER OUR COUNTY BY WINNER. BY
WILK HI. YEAH. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GALGIANI HI.
JONES MITCHELL HI MORE LOCK.
PAN HI. I THIRTY SIX KNOWS TO
THE PRIME MINISTER IS CONFIRMED
REMOVE BACK ON A FILE NUMBER
THIRTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN. I LET THE CALL. THE CARD
NOT COLLEGE ALLEN. HI BELL HI
DOT. DORADO HI GALGIANI BY
JONES MITCHELL I MORE LOCK BY
RUBIO. WHY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD I JONES. I
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN SENATOR DODD. I
MEAN WILK SOME SORRY. THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME AND
PRESIDENT. ANYWAY DATA
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR AMY HORN
FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD Là
HOUGHTON REGION DR HORN IS
SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE AND SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON THE FOURTEENTH OF AUGUST. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BELL I PORGES HI BRADFORD. I
CAN BE AT ALL HI JANE. HI DOLLY%
DODD HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ. HI GROVE
I HERTZBERG. BY HILL AYE HUESO
HI TITLE. JACKSON HI JONES
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE I MITCHELL.
HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK MORRELL.
NO NIELSEN PAN BY PORTANTINO. I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY
STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER OUR
COUNTY. BY WINNER BY WILK BY.
SENATOR WILK MOVES CALL. MOVING
ITEM ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
SENATOR WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FOUND ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
WATER CONTROL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD APPOINTMENTS
PETER SADDENED TO THE COLORADO
RIVER BASIN REGION ABOARD
DOCTOR KIMBERLY **** FOR
REPORTING REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
LA HOT AND BORED DR JAMES DAHLE
AND DANIEL TELL ALI IN TO THE
LOS ANGELES BOARD HECTOR BUT
DOLE OUT FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO
THE NORTH COAST BOARD AND
KRISTEN MARIE TO THE SANTA ANA
BOARD. THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH WITH THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE OR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARE SO THAT A
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL I
PORCHES I BRADFORD. I COUNTY AT
ALL HI I CHIANG I DALY I DODD
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO. JACKSON HI JONES LEYVA
I'M ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK I AM A
REAL BY NELSON HI OPINION I
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN. BY STONE. I
AM BURKE I WOULD COUNTY BY
WINNER BY WILK HI. SENATOR WILL
MOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS ARE
READY TO MOVE ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. WE WILL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN. SORRY
SENATOR PORTANTINO SENATOR
PORTANTINO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY FIVE A SENATOR PORTANTINO
ANAK RULING THE JOINT POWERS.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS HAVE
PRESENTING SB THREE FIVE FIVE
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
SENATE AUTHORIZED THE CLEAN
POWER ALLIANCE OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW CERTAIN
ALTERNATIVE MEMBERS OF ITS
LEGISLATIVE BODY O ATTEND
CLOSE SESSIONS OF THE AGENCIES
AMENDMENTS OUR TECHNICAL. AND
NARROWED THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BILL I PURCHASED I
BRADFORD. I CARILLO I CHIANG. I
DALY AYE DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO.
JACKSON HI JONES. LEYVA BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. BY MORNING
BY MORE LOCK ARM RELL. I
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN I STONE I AM BURKE BOB
OWSKI AYE WIENER AYE WILK HI.
SENATOR PORTANTINO MOVES THE
CALL. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY.
SENATOR SKINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO
FAMILY DAYCARE HOMES. CENTER
SKINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB TWO THIRTY FOURS
BACK FROM CONCURRENCE IT
INCREASES THE AVAILABILITY OF
QUALITY OR WILL INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF QUALITY
AFFORDABLE AND LOCAL CHILD CARE
THERE WERE MINOR AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY THE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. HI BILL BY BURGESS I
BRADFORD. HI KELLY AT ALL HI I
CHIANG I DALY I DODD I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. BY TITLE. I JACKSON
I JONES LEYVA. I AM A CHOIR AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL. BY NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN I
STONE. HI NUMBER OUR COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK. HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE
JONES. ICE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZEROS THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE AND STUDENT
SAFETY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT TODAY I RISE TO
SHARE THE AMENDMENTS SB THREE
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER INSTEAD
LATE IMPLEMENTATION OF PROVIDE
UC CAMPUSES WITH FLEXIBILITY IF
THEY HAVE LOCAL RESOURCES ON
PRINTING THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOTLINE ON THE BACK OF
ID CARDS. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH THANK YOU. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE THIS CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BILL. I PURCHASED AYE
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO HI I CHIANG
I DALY AYE DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO BY TADO BY JACKSON. I
JONES LEYVA. MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LUCK I AM A REAL. NIELSEN. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. BY STERN I
STONE. I AM BURKE I WOULD
COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GROWTH JONES LEYVA HI MORRELL.
I THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS HEROES THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO SENATOR
SKINNER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOR NINETEEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE DISCIPLINE.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS SB FOR NINETEEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. OUR ROLE
IS TO KEEP KIDS IN SCHOOL AND
TO HELP THEM SUCCEED WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AS YOU HAVE HEARD IT
BEFORE IS ELIMINATE EIGHT
ARBITRARY AND SUBJECTIVE
CATEGORY OF SUSPENSIONS THAT A
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE HAVE ALREADY
ELIMINATED. AND THAT CATEGORY
OF SUSPENSIONS IS WILLFUL
DEFIANCE THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ADJUSTED THE BILL TO
MAKE GRADE LEVELS FORD IN FIVE
PERMANENT AND- ONLY EXTEND
GRADE LEVELS. SIX TO EIGHT FOR
FIVE YEARS SO THE GRADE LEVEL
SIXTY EIGHT WOULD SUNSET IN
FIVE YEARS. SB FOR NINETEEN IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
THEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BELL I PORCHES. BRADFORD. HI
KELLY YELLOW I CHIANG I DALY NO
DODD HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TADO. HI JACKSON BY JONES
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LUCK. NO
MORRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN BY STONE NO
NUMBER. OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK BY. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GORGEOUS NO. GROVE
JONES. I THIRTY ONE KNOWS SEVEN
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE SENATOR
MONNING MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MONNING AN ACT
RELATING TO CANNABIS
CULTIVATION. FOR IS YOURS
MISTER MONEY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THE SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THE
AUTHORITY FOR A COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER TO
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE ON THE
CONDITION. ACRE PRODUCTION AND
VALUE OF CANNABIS AS AN
ADDENDUM TO ITS ANNUAL CROP
REPORT THIS IS PERMISSIVE NOT
MANDATORY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE THIS CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL I PURCHASE. NO
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO HI HI JANE.
I DALY HI DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE HI
JACKSON BY JONES LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MORNING I'M MORE LUCK I AM A
REAL. NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
HI NUMBER FIVE A CASKEY. BY
WINNER BY WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH JONES.
ICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR. THE
ASSEMBLY MEET AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR SENATOR
MORALE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR MORAL MORALE RELATIVE
TO UNITED STATES FOREST SERVICE
FIREFIGHTER BRENT MICHAEL WITH
THEM MEMORIAL HIGHWAY. SENATOR
MOREAU THANK YOU WELL GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS. I'M HONORED
TODAY TO PRESENT A S. C. R.
THIRTY TWO ON BEHALF. OF ONE OF
OUR FALLEN HEROES FROM MY
DISTRICT A SELFLESS YOUNG MAN.
WHO WE RECOGNIZE HE WORKED
ALONGSIDE MEN AND WOMEN SERVING
AS THE WILDLAND FIREFIGHTERS
WITH THE UNITED STATES FOR
SERVICE. PROTECT THE MILLIONS
OF ACRES OF OUR FORCE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND MUCH OF OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES IT'S A
DIFFICULT AND DANGEROUS JOB AS
I THINK WE ALL KNOW A- IS ALSO
THOSE EVIDENCE BY THE DEATH OF
US FOR SERVICE FIREFIGHTER
BRENT MICHAEL WYNNUM. LOSSES
LIFE IN THE LINE A SERVICE WHEN
WAS A MEMBER OF ONE OF THE
ELITE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN HOT
SHOT IS IN THE UNITED STATES
TASK THE CHALLENGING JOB OF
EITHER HIKING. BEING AIR
DROPPED TO REMOTE AREAS OF THE
WILDERNESS TO FIGHT FIRES.
SERVICEMEN WHITMAN WAS ONLY
TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD AT THE
TIME OF HIS PASSING ON LOSSES
LIFE IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
AUGUST SECOND TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WILL WORKING ARE IN
WESTERN MONTANA ON A LARGE FIRE
BUT YET TWO YEARS LATER AFTER
HIS PASSING HE'S REMEMBERED BY
HIS FELLOW FIREFIGHTERS WHO
MISSED SAME HIS SURVIVING
FAMILY A LOVE ONES WHO HONOR
HIS MEMORY ANNUALLY SO IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS MAN
SERVICE TWO S. C. R. THIRTY TWO
WHICH DESIGNATES A PORTION OF
STATE ROUTE THIRTY EIGHT. NEAR
THE COMMUNITY OF THE SAM COUNTY
SAN MARINO MOUNTAINS IN THE
CITY OF MEN TOWN AS THE US FOR
SERVICE FIREFIGHTER BRET
MICHAEL WHEN I'M MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BY BATES HI BILL I
PORGES BY BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
I CHIANG I DALY I DODD ARE
THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI BY
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO I JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCKED I AM A
REAL I NIELSEN I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN BY STONE. I AM
BURKE. FIVE A COUNTY BY WINNER.
BY WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH. JONES
SKINNER. I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT HAS A MOTION AS SOLUTION
CENTER DOLLY. LIKE TO REMOVE
FILE AND TWO SEVENTY EIGHT AB
TEN EIGHTY ONE. DID ANYONE FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT SO I WAS
AB TEN EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE
. MEMBERS WERE
STILL ON MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS
. SENATOR HUESO
UNDER OUR MOST MOTIONS RIDGE
RESOLUTIONS AND LIKE TO THIS IS
RELATED TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE PULL FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY FIVE A.
B. TEN EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE. I RELATED TO
SPECIAL CONSENT IT'S SO ORDERED.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO GO BACK
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR PAN BUT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IS MY
PRIVILEGE TO HONOR THE FACT
FAMILY AS WE RECOGNIZE THE
EIGHTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF FRANK
FATS RESTAURANT. I THINK MANY
OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH FRANK
FATS WONDERFUL RESTAURANT IT'S
KNOWN FOR THE FAMOUS BANANA
CREAM PIES AFTER WHICH WE
DEFINITELY HAVE TO WALK BACK TO
THE CAPITAL. AND CERTAINLY
HOLDS MANY REYES OF OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY MAY POLITICAL
LUMINARIES INCLUDING EVERY
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR SINCE WORLD
WAR HAS DYING THERE THAT'S IT
OPENED IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE.
AND FRANK FATS WAS PART OF AN
ERA WHEN DEAL MAKING TOOK OFF
AND TOOK PLACE OVER MEALS
BETWEEN LEGISLATORS AND
LOBBYISTS. PERHAPS THE MOST
FAMOUS STEEL AFTER THAT A DEAL
THAT I PERSONALLY AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF WAS BROKERED A
FRANK FATS WITH THE LEGENDARY
NAPKIN DEAL THAT RESULTED IN
MEDICAL LIABILITY REFORM.
BEHIND THE SUCCESSFUL
RESTAURANT THOUGH IS THE STORY
OF AN UNDOCUMENTED CHINESE
IMMIGRANT ENCHANTED BY
AMERICA'S GOLD MOUNTAIN FRANK
FAT. DESPITE THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT FRANK IMMIGRATED
TO THE U. S. AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN. HE WAS DETAINED AT
ANGEL ISLAND IMMIGRATION
STATION AND AFTER HIS RELEASE
HE WORKED AS A FRUIT PACKER A
DISHWASHER. AND WAITER INTEL HE
RECEIVED A LUCKY BREAK FROM A
RESTAURANT PATRONS. BECAUSE
FRANK HAD HELD ON TO THE CASH
EARNINGS OF A CUSTOMER WHO HAD
PURCHASED A KINO TICKET. AND
LEFT BEFORE THE GAME BEGAN. AND
APPRECIATION OF FRANK'S HONESTY
THE CUSTOMER HELP THEM SECURE A
LOAN FOR IN THE PURCHASE OF
PROPERTY AT EIGHT OF SIX L.
STREET. FRANK FATS RESTAURANT
SUCCESS WAS BORN OUT OF HARD
WORK KINDNESS AND THE DREAMS OF
IMMIGRANT. FRANK IN THIS
RESTAURANT A SYMBOL OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM AND I DARE SAY
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM AN
ILLUSTRATION OF THE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS IMMIGRANTS MAKE
TO OUR SOCIETY OUR COMMUNITY.
BREAK THAT'S A STILL A FAMILY
BUSINESS TODAY WITH THREE OTHER
RESTAURANTS AND CATERING
BUSINESS RECENTLY EARNING THE
TWENTY NINETEEN MICHELIN BIB
GOURMAND AND A JAMES BEARD
AMERICA'S CLASSICS AWARD. SO
JOINING US TODAY ARE THREE
GENERATIONS OF THE FAT FAMILY
AND I'M GONNA SO WE HAVE IN IN
BOTH THE RESTAURANT AND I HAVE
TO SAY IT'S ALWAYS THE DENTIST
ALSO IN THE DENTAL COMMUNITY
THEY LEAD AS WELL. YOU'LL FIND
OUT MY RUN SO WE HAVE JERRY FAT
PRESIDENT CEO FRANKS AND HIS
SON. YOU KEVIN. KEVIN.
POLITICALLY FLAWS AT THE END
BUT EVAN DOESN'T FOR DESERVE
APPLAUSE KEVIN FASCIO FRANK'S
MANSON CAM LENA FAT HEAD OF
COLONY RESEARCH FOOD OPERATIONS
FRANK'S DAUGHTER IN LAW. KEVIN
CAN FAT FREDDY'S SON IN THE
LOCAL DENTIST. ONE AT THEIR
FIRST AS THE- KOREAN FACT SHEET
FRANK'S GRANDDAUGHTER RICHIE
KOREANS HUSBAND. WELL IN FACT
FRANK'S GRANDSON FORMER FRANK
FACTS DIEM AND JOHN MANAGER
CASEY FAT LOCAL OR AND HONEST
THANKS GRANDSON THE SECOND AND.
STREAM FAT LOCAL DENTIST THE
JAYCEES WIFE. MICHELLE FAT
FRANKS GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER.
MICHAEL FAT FRANKS GREAT
GRANDSON. AND. JAMIE GETS LIDA
MARKETING MANAGER FAT FAMILY
RESTAURANTS. OKAY SO AGAIN
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
THE EIGHTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
FRANK FATS AND PLEASE WISH THEM
SUCCESS FOR DECADES OF THE
CENTURY SCOTT. THE RESTAURANT.
YES MADAM PRO TEM THANK YOU. HI
I KNOW WE'RE ALL EXCITED TO GET
TO SHAKE HANDS AND JOINING MY
COLLEAGUE DR PAY AND WE KNOW
SAID SACRAMENTO HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF TERRIFIC DINING AND
CERTAINLY HISTORY FRANK FATS.
HOW MANY OF US HAD BANANA CREAM
PIE FOR BREAKFAST. YES I DID HI
IT WAS THERE ARE WE LOVE FRANK
FADS AND WE'RE PROUD TO
COMMEMORATE THE EIGHTIETH
ANNIVERSARY BUT FOR ME I WANT
TO TAKE A LITTLE FURTHER SOUTH
IF I MAY OUT OF RESPECT TO THE
FAMILY I. N. A. ONCE ABILITY TO
DIVEST FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY SAN DIEGO THE FAT
FAMILY LEGACY ALSO HAS A
CONNECTION TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
THANKS TO THE TIRELESS WORK OF
TOM FAT ONE OF FRANKS SONS.
WITH THE ORIGINAL FRANK FATS
THRIVING ON ELSTREE TOM
VENTURED TO SAN DIEGO IN THE
SEVENTIES TO EXPAND THE
FAMILY'S BUSINESS HE CAME TO
THE RESCUE OF AN ICONIC BRIGHT
PINK ART DECO BUILDING ON THE
PACIFIC COAST HIGHWAY THAT IT
ONCE BEEN HOME TO THE NINETEEN
FORTIES NIGHT CLUB POSTING
LEGENDS LIKE KING COLE AND
SHELLEY WINTERS TOM TURNED IT
INTO TWO RESTAURANTS FAT CITY
AND CHINA CAMP A TWO FOLD
TREASURE THAT RE ENERGIZED THE
DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO RESTAURANT
SCENE. I FIND MEMORIES OF GOING
TO FAT CITY IN CHINA CAMP WHICH
BOASTED FANTASTIC ASIAN CUISINE
IN ADDITION TO BEAUTIFUL
GARDENS AND A COLLECTION OF
HISTORIC MACHINERY FROM THE OLD
MINING DAYS. LUNCH WAS WHEN
ELECTED OFFICIALS GATHERED TO
HOLD COURT SOME EVEN IF IT
BECAME A THING TO LEAVE A
SPECIAL TRINKET BEHIND ADDED TO
THE COUNTLESS STATUTES AND
KNICKKNACKS THAT DECORATED. THE
RESTAURANT SHELVES. BUT TOM'S
LEGACY WASN'T ONLY CONTAINED IN
HIS SAN DIEGO RESTAURANTS ARE
THE MANY MORE THAT HE WOULD
HELP OPEN AS HIS FAMILY
BUSINESS BUSINESSES FLOURISHED
OVER THE DECADES. TOM WAS A
RIVER CITY CIVIC LEADER. HE WAS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE. AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THIS THAT IF YOU
WANTED TO GET ENGAGED CIVIC LEE
ARE YOU WANTED TO RUN FOR
OFFICE YOU ACTUALLY HAD TO SIT
DOWN WITH TOM. BECAUSE HE WOULD
GIVE YOU GREAT ADVICE AND HE
WAS ONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS. I
THAT REALLY TOOK EVERYTHING TO
HEART AND YOU WERE WISE IF YOU
DIDN'T. MISS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT AND TALK TO HIM ABOUT STATE
POLITICS HE WAS A LUMINARY
WITHIN SAN DIEGO'S ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY.
WHEN TOM PASSED AWAY AFTER A
BATTLE WITH CANCER IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HE WAS DESCRIBED
AS THE HEART SOUL IN SOME WAYS
THE CONSCIENCE OF SAN DIEGO'S
API COMMUNITY INDEED HE WAS.
BUT I WOULD SAY IT WENT BEYOND
THE API COMMUNITY. JOHNNY CAM
HAS SINCE CLOSED INVESTED WAS
REPLACED BY ANOTHER RESTAURANT
AND HOTEL SAN DIEGANS STILL
TALK FINALLY ABOUT WHAT WAS
ONCE THERE. TWO BEAUTIFUL
RESTAURANTS A MAN WHO SHARED
HIS FAMILY'S LEGACY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HIS BOUNDLESS ENERGY
AND LOVE FOR SAN DIEGO WITH ALL
OF US SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR FAMILY WITH
THOSE OF US NOT JUST IN
SACRAMENTO. BUT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THANKS
. YEAH
. YEAH.
A BIG SENATE WELCOME TO THE
FACT THAT FAMILY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CULINARY DELIGHTS IN FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK. TO OUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
WE HAVE FINISHED. WITH THE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO SENATE THIRD READING.
SENATOR DODD HE DIED. LEAST I
THINK WE WELL IF WE CAN FIND
SENATOR DIED. WE FOUND HIM.
SENATOR DODD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ WE'RE ON SENATE
THIRD READING CENTER TO. ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY ONE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
BY SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
WEEK. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA WEEK WOULD PROVIDE A
PLATFORM TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND IMPACT OF THE
DELTA REGION. THE DELTA IS THE
HEART OF CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SYSTEM AND PRODUCES CROPS WORTH
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EACH YEAR HELPING TO FEED THE
WORLD. AS ONE OF THE LARGEST
ESTUARIES IN WESTERN NORTH
AMERICA THE DELTA IS HOME TO
FIVE HUNDRED PLANT AND ANIMAL
SPECIES. THE SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN DELTA WEEK WOULD
ENCOURAGE VOLUNTARY VANCE TO
CLEAN UP AND REMOVE TRASH FROM
THE DELTA AND RESTORE THE
HEALTH OF THE REGION'S WATER
WAYS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES HI BILL I
PORGES HI BRADFORD. I CAL HERO
I CHIANG I DALY I DODD. DODD.
HI THERE ALSO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WITH SO I
OUR TITLE I JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. BY
MORRELL. NIELSEN. HI PAN I
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE. I
AM BURKE OUR CASKEY. I WIENER
AYE WILK HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE HI. JONES
MORRELL. ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THAT WERE DONE WITH THE
SENATE THIRD READING SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. AND WE
WILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
FORTY NINE. SENATOR MONNING
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
AN ACT RELATING TO SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. CLASSIFIED
STAFF IN BOTH MERIT IN NON
MERIT SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMPLETE
WORK BY THE SAME STANDARDS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER DISTRICT
IS MERIT DISTRICT OR NON MERIT
DISTRICT HOWEVER CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES IN A NON MERIT
DISTRICT HAVE A LONGER
PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF ONE YEAR
WHERE'S THE MERIT DISTRICT
ALLOWS FOR A SIX MONTH
PROBATIONARY PERIOD AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY THREE WILL CONFORM AND
CLARIFY FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
CLASSIFIED STAFF BY ALLOWING
CLASS EMPLOYEES IN NOT.
DISTRICTS TO OBTAIN PERMANENT
STATUS IN A SIX MONTH
PROBATIONARY PERIOD MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR RUBIO. YES THANK
YOU IT TODAY I REYES AND I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BUT I REALLY WANT TO CAUTION US
AS A SCHOOL. EMPLOYEE MY SO
OFTEN ADMINISTRATOR I THINK OP
OUR GOAL SHOULD BE TO EXTEND
THE PROBATIONARY PERIOD FOR
EVERYONE I THINK SOMETIMES WHEN
WEEK. LORD THE THAT THE OUR
PROBATION PERIOD WHAT HAPPENS
SOMETIMES ADMINISTRATORS ARE
NOT READY TO MAKE A DECISION ON
THAT EMPLOYEE AND INSTEAD OF
HELPING THE EMPLOYEE WE END UP.
ARE PRESSURING ADINISTRATION
TO LET THEM GO OR YEAR AND SO I
JUST WANT US TO THINK IN THE
FUTURE OF EXTENDING OF
PROBATIONARY PERIOD BECAUSE-
THAT GIVES ADMINISTRATORS TIME
TO REALLY. ALLOW AN EMPLOYEE TO
FLOURISH AND MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION TO KEEP THEM. AND
SOMETIMES A FINANCES ARE NOT
THERE SO I WILL SUPPORT IT BUT-
I WANT TO BE MY FOR THAT THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION EIGHT.
THING MAN SENATOR MONNING YOU
MAY CONCLUDE YES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST COMMENT PRE SHEET
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT ABOUT 60% OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES TODAY. DO
YOU HAVE THE SIX MONTH
PROBATIONARY PERIOD THAN THOSE
IN THE OTHER SYSTEM IT'S A
SUBJECT OF BARGAINING AND WHAT
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO IS
TO REALLY BRING UNIFORMITY AND
PREDICTABILITY AND WE FOUND
THAT DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE SIX MONTH
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. THOSE
REASONS I'D REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. NO BELL I
PURCHASED NO BRADFORD HI COPY
AT ALL. CHIANG NO DALY NO DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO I GALGIANI HI
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
HI TITLE HI. JACKSON HI JONES
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
HI MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. NO
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI. ROUGH RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN I STONE NO
NUMBER. BY COUNTY BY WINNER HI
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS. ZERO JONES ROTH.
NUMBER NUMBER GUY. ICE TWENTY
FIVE NO ELEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY TWO SENATOR
MCGUIRE. PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE AWAY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION. IS YOURS A GOOD
MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
RIGHTS PRESENT SO NUMBER. PHIL
TING SAID AB TWELVE OH EIGHT
THIS BILL IS PRETTY SIMPLE
SIMPLY SENDS A SUNSET ON
EXISTING LAW THAT PROHIBITS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FROM
ASSESSING UTILITY USER TAXES ON
CUSTOMER ON CLEAN ELECTRICITY
SUCH AS ROOFTOP SOLAR OR EVEN
FUEL CELLS AB TWELVE OH EIGHT
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. PRECIADO ST
NUMBER TEAMS HARD WORK ON THIS
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM
NINE FOUR NINE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THING NINE MEMBER MEMBER
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE. I IS THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY TWO. SENATOR
CHIANG. OKAY
. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW ENACT REALLY INTO
HEALING ARTS CENTER CHIANG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB SEVEN SEVENTY NINE
WAS INTENT WHICH IS INTENDED TO
IMPROVE THE ACTIVE POSTER
BOARDS ENFORCEMENT PROCESS THIS
BILL CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE MAKING
IT CLEAR LICENSEE MUST REGISTER
NEW PLACES A PRACTICE.
CURRENTLY LICENSEES ARE ONLY
REQUIRED TO REGISTER. WHEN THEY
FIRST APPLY FOR LICENSE OR
CHANGE THE LOCATION OF THE
REGISTER PLACE PRACTICE. IT
ALSO ESTABLISHED A NEW YSTEM
OF WALL LICENSES THERE ARE
SPECIFIC TO EACH LOCATION. THIS
IS INTENDED TO TURN PRACTICE OF
SELLING OR RENTING OF LICENSES.
WITH THAT I WOULD REQUEST NAY
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS THIS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. THING
NINE. ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR CENTER LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AND
ACT REALLY INTO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOR YEARS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH FOUR
DUE TO A LACK OF RESOURCES THE
STUDENTS SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAS VIRTUALLY NO PRESENCE IN
THE STATE CAPITOL AND LITTLE TO
NO ABILITY TO ADVOCATE FOR
LEGISLATION THAT AFFECTS.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
WILL ENSURE THAT A TWO DOLLAR
STUDENT REPRESENTATION FEE IS
IMPLEMENTED AT ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY
COLLECTING IT FROM ALL STUDENTS
UPON PAYMENT OF REGISTRATION
HOWEVER THEY MAY OPT OUT IF
THEY DO NOT WANT TO PAY FOR IT.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
COMMUNICORP STUDENTS HAVE AN
EQUAL VOICE WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICIES AND LEGISLATION THAT
IMPACTS THEM MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CLUB OR CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES NO
BELL I PORGES NOBEL. BILL AYE
BRADFORD HI CARRIER I CHIANG.
DALY NO DODD. HI DORADO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW NO HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. I TITLE. JACKSON I JONES
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
HI MONEY I MORE LOCK NO MORRELL
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO BY ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY STERN I STONE NO
NUMBER I WORK OUT SEE. I WINNER
BY WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS CHIANG. NO TITLE. JONES.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN NOTEKNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY NINE SENATOR
ALLEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. THE BILL. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE. MEMBERS
AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN PROVIDES
CLARITY TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESIDENTS AND
DEVELOPERS ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
AN UPDATED COMMUNITY PLAN SAID
IT'S ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT BE
CHALLENGED IN COURT. WHILE MOST
JURISDICTIONS AT THE TO LEND
YOU SOME IN THEIR GENERAL PLANS
PART THE GENERAL PLAN UPDATE.
THOSE WITH MULTIPLE COMMUNITY
PLAN AREAS UPDATE THESE
DOCUMENTS INDIVIDUALLY
REQUIRING COMMITTEE PLANS TO
THEN BE REVIEWED INDIVIDUALLY.
MANY THESE PLANS HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED IN RECENT YEARS TO
REFLECT CHANGING LOCAL
PRIORITIES AS WELL AS THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL ON
HOUSING GOALS BECAUSE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY THE RESULTS IF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW DOCUMENT
PREPARED FOR THE UPDATE IS
CHALLENGED. IN COURT. DURING
THE LITIGATION PROCESS IT'S AN
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE ORIGINAL
COMMUNITY PLAN OR AT THE
UPDATE. IS IN EFFECT CAUSING
GREAT UNCERTAINTY AND
POTENTIALLY STALLING ALL
DEVELOPMENT IS CERTAINLY
INCREASING COSTS. UNDER THIS
BILL DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT
WOULD APPROVED OR DEEMED
COMPLIANT A COMPLETE PRIOR TO A
COURT ISSUED WRIT TO RESCIND OR
VûI THE UPDATEDCOMMITTEE
PLAN CANNOT BE INVALID BY THE
COURT THIS NEARLY TAYLOR IT
MAINTAINS INTEGRITY OF THE
SECRET PROCESS. AND DOES NOT
PROHIBIT PLANS ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW FROM BEING CHALLENGED
FINALLY THE BILL WOULD ONLY
APPLY TO COMMUNITY PLANS AT A
MET A HIGH SET OF CRITERIA INTO
THE VANCE AND LOCAL AND STATE
PRIORITIES INCLUDING. HOUSING
AN ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS THE BILL
IS SPONSORED BY LA MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IT'S ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECT FESTIVAL.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CENTER HERTZBERG
THANK YOU MADAM PRESENT JUST
BRIEFLY I WANT TO JOIN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THE
pEVERYTHING POSSIBLE ON IF NOT
WE'LL MAKE SURE THEY DO MORE
THINGS POSSIBLE TO DEAL WITH
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN HOMELESS
CRISIS THAT WE FACE THIS IS AN
INTEGRAL PART. OF THAT LARGER
EFFORT ON THEIR BEHALF FIVE MET
NUMBER OF THE LA CITY A HOUSING
FOLKS AND JUST WANTED TO STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE TODAY. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
MISSED. SENATOR ALLEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I AM AT THE I
THINK THE GOOD CENTER FROM
SEVEN IN A VALLEY AND RESPECT
REST MY VOTE. YOUR SECRETARY.
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NONE. ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTY EIGHT.
SENATOR ALAN. MISTER SECRETARY.
THE THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. CENTER ON THE RIGHT
OR IS IT IN MEMBERS THIS BILL
AB SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS- THE
VOTER PROTECTION ACT WONDERFUL.
AUGUST THE GIVEN TO IT BY ITS
ASSEMBLY AUTHOR IT WOULD
ADDRESS VOTER COERCIONAND
PROTECT OUT INTEGRITY BY
PROHIBITING ON EMPLOYER FROM
REQUIRING OR REQUESTING. THAT
AN EMPLOYEE BRING THEIR VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT TO WORK. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT PROHIBIT ACTS
OF VOTER INTIMIDATION AND
COERCION BY THE CALIFORNIA
ACTIONS CODE DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBIT EMPLOYERS
FROM REQUESTING REQUIRING
EMPLOYEES. TO BRING THEIR VOTE
BY MAIL ABOUT INTO WORKER VOTE
THEIR VOTE BY MAIL ABOUT IT AT
WORK. THE NEW THERE HAVE BEEN A
COUPLE CONCERNS OUT THERE THAT
ARE BEING ADDRESSED BY THIS
BILL VOTERS REALLY OUGHT TO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO CAST ABOUT
WITHOUT THE FEAR THEIR
EMPLOYER. OR A FELLOW EMPLOYEE
LOOKING OVER THEIR SHOULDER NOW
THAT WE'RE GETTING MORE VOTE BY
MAIL MAIL OUT THERE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
REALLY STRONG PROTECTIONS LIKE
THIS. AND THAT'S WHY I WAS A
FRESHMAN VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SAYING THEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN HI I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES I BILL
I PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY. DOT.
BY THE RAZA AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ BY GROW.
HERTZBERG I HILL HI HUESO. HI
TITLE BY JACKSON. BY JONES.
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LUCK I AM
A REAL. NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER BY STERN. BY STONE.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY. HI AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BRADFORD HI. DALY GROWTH. JONES
MORRELL. STONE. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY NINE AND A
LITTLE BIT UNUSUAL BUT SENATOR
DOLLY GETS TO PRESENT HIS OWN
BILL FROM THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TALLY AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATOR
DOLLY THAT FOR YEARS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS
A- NICE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
MY OWN BILLS. AB ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT TODAY IMPRISONING AB ONE
TODAY THAT WILL CREATE A NEW
NARAL EXEMPTION. MANDATORY
SOLAR. FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR HOMES DUE TO CATASTROPHIC
EVENT WHEN THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY HAS BEEN DECLARED BY
THE GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE SEVERAL CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH DESTROYED ONE
POINT SIX MILLION ACRES OF LAND
AND THOUSANDS OF HOMES. SO
THESE HOMES. WERE UNDER INSURED
AND WITH ALL. OF THE INCREASED
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
REBUILDING DUE TO THE NEW
BUILDING STANDARDS IS MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS TO REBUILD. THE COST OF
SOLAR SYSTEMS CAN ALONE ADD UP
TO TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
COSTS REBUILD AB ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT WILL GIVE A NARROW
EXEMPTION. FROM THIS MANDATE TO
THOSE WHO. MEET A CERTAIN
CRITERIA SUCH AS INCOME
INSURANCE COVERAGE LIMITATIONS.
THIS WILL GIVE THE NECESSARY
LEE FOR SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO REBUILD THEIR HOMES
AND WHO ARE STARTING TO PUT
THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER. OF
COURSE IF THEY WISH TO CHOOSE
TO PUT SOLAR ON THEY MAY. LET'S
HELP THE PEOPLE REBUILD THEIR
HOMES AND LIVES. THIS BILL IS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR RESO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE REVIEWED THIS
BILL IN COMMITTEE AND SIMPLY
ONE OF THE QUESTIONSWE CAN ASK
AND I'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
TO THE AUTHOR REGARDING THE
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THIS BILL AS
AS AS WE ALL KNOW HE'S A BIG
CHAMPION FOR BIO MASS WHAT IS
GOING TO BE THE FISCAL IMPACT
BY A MASS OF PEOPLE ADDING MORE
SOLAR TO THEIR HOMES THROUGH
THE CHAIR SENATOR DOLLY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU'LL ABSOLUTELY I'D LOVE TO
TALK ABOUT BY MASS. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION IS IT WILL NOT
ACTUALLY IMPACT BY OUT SOME AS
YOU KNOW. WE'RE REQUIRED TO PUT
SOLAR ON ROOFS AND- WE HAVE WE
ARE WE'RE ACTUALLY PRODUCING
MORE SOLAR THAN WE ACTUALLY
NEED IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
DIVERTING THAT OTHER STATES SO.
THE BIOMASS CONTRACTS THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US NOW ARE
REALLY CRITICAL BECAUSE THE
WHEN THE SUN IS NOT SHINING IN
THE WIND'S NOT BLOWING THEY
ACTUALLY PRODUCE GREEN POWER
SO. IT'LL ACTUALLY I THINK
HELP. ON THE ACE REALLY THIS
BILLS ABOUT GETTING THOSE FOLKS
WHO LOST THEIR HOMES WHO DIDN'T
HAVE INSURANCE ON THEIR SOLAR
SO. I THINK IT WILL ACTUALLY
HELP THE BAHAMAS INDUSTRY. OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF. SEND
THEM WE ARE PRODUCING MORE
SOLAR THAN WE NEED IN THE
STATE'S AYE. I RECOMMEND A NO
VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
TO. WIENER WIENER BUT- I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL I UDERSTAND THE
INTENT BEHIND THE BILL AND I AM
SYMPATHETIC TO THE NEEDS OF
THESE ARE HOMEOWNERS TO BE ABLE
TO REBUILD QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AND THE REASON
HOWEVER THAT I'M OPPOSE THE
BILL IS THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT A
NARROW EXEMPTION THIS IS QUITE
BROAD IT DOESN'T JUST APPLY TO
A FEW SPECIFIC OF THE HORRIFIC
FIRES THAT HAPPENED IT APPLIES
IN ANY DISASTER NATURAL
DISASTER. THAT'S BEEN DECLARED
WITH NO START TIME. AND IN
FIFTY SEVEN OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES DISASTERS HAVE BEEN
DECLARED SO THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE CAMPFIRE OR SOME OF
THE GROUP OF BUYERS IN THE
NORTH BAY. OR MENTOR COUNTY
THIS APPLIES MUCH MORE BOADLY
THIS IS A LARGE EXEMPTION. FROM
THE SOLAR ROOF TOP REQUIREMENT
WHICH IS PART OF CALIFORNIA
OFFERED TO A 100% PAUL. ENERGY
.
OUR FAILED INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY MODEL AND SO THIS IS I
THINK AN IMPORTANT WAY OF
LOWERING COSTS NOT INCREASE
COSTS. I AM FINALLY ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE HAVE HAD THESE
HORRIFIC FIRES IS CALIFORNIA'S
ADDICTION TO INFINITE EXPANSION
OF DISTRIBUTION AND
TRANSMISSION WIRES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT INSTEAD OF
MOVING TOWARDS A MORE
DECENTRALIZED D. E. R. MODEL WE
HAVE CONTINUALLY INCREASES
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH INCREASES
THE RISK OF WILDFIRE. WE KNOW
THE DVR'S INCREASE RESILIENCE
NOT ONLY DOES IT. DECREASE THE
NEED TO. EXPANDING THIS SYSTEM
THAT RISKS WILDFIRES BUT IT
ALSO ENSURES THAT WHEN A WHAT
WHO WHEN THE SYSTEM GOES DOWN.
AND WE KNOW THAT P. GINNY THEY
MIGHT DO MASSIVE POWER SHUT
DOWNS THROUGHOUT THEIR SERVICE
TO OUR TERRITORY. THAT PEOPLE
CAN STILL HAVE ENERGY BECAUSE
OF THE SOLAR AND THE STORAGE SO
I JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE RIGHT DIRECTION IF THIS
WERE A VERY VERY NARROW
TARGETED APPROACH WE COULD HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION BUT IT IS
ACTUALLY NOT NARROW IT'S QUITE
BROAD I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO
VOTE. SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I APPRECIATE
THE. THE SENSITIVITY OF THE
ISSUE GIVEN THE TRAGEDIES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED ALL OVER THIS
STATE I'VE BEEN THROUGH IT
MYSELF AFTER THE WILL THE FIRE
AND WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
RECOVERY AND REBUILDING PROCESS
OURSELVES RIGHT NOW. PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET BACK INTO SMALL
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES SCHOOL
TEACHERS NURSES FIREFIGHTERS
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE TRYING TO
GET THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK.
I'M NOT GONNA BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BE DENYING. THOSE
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
REBUILD. AN OPPORTUNITY
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY. ON IN THE
LONG TERM AND FRANKLY IN THE
SHORT TERM THERE'S NOT A SOLAR
ROOF MANDATE. YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
DOWNSIZE IN FACT THE SIZE OF
THE GENERATION IF YOU'RE TAKING
INTO EFFECT OTHER ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES THAT YOUR
HOME. USING GREENER BUILDING
MATERIALS AND YOU'RE USING
STORAGE NOW THE CODE DOES SAY
IF YOU DON'T TAKE ANY OF THOSE
MEASURES YOU DO HAVE TO INSTALL
PAN. AND THAT DOES HAVE UP
FRONT COST I THINK THE ANALYSIS
SITTING ON THE FLOOR TALKS
ABOUT ABOUT. AT TEN THOUSAND OR
MORE. THE CALCULATIONS FROM THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ARE TWENTY
THOUSAND OR MORE IN SAVINGS IN
FACT. AND SO THAT SAVINGS TO
NINE HOMEOWNERS THE OPPORTUNITY
THE CHOICE TO ACTUALLY SAVE
THAT MONEY OVER TIME TO ME
SEEMS ILL FOUNDED. END AND
FURTHER MORE YOU KNOW I JUST I
HAVE TO PUSH BACK ON THE
PRINCIPLE OF OVER GENERATION
THAT THERE'S TOO MUCH SOLAR IN
THIS STATE. IN FACT. SO THERE
IS THE CHEAPEST FORM OF ENERGY
BEING PRODUCED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TODAY. ENDS OVER
GENERATING SOLAR AS THE LA
TIMES HAS REPORTED ON THE VERY
FRONT PAGE OF THEIR PAPER.
BASED ON TWO RECENT ANALYSES
THAT OVER GENERATION. IS
CHEAPER THAN RUNNING LARGE
HEAVY ACRE PLANTS AT THAT SAME
TIME CURTAILING THAT GENERATION
DURING THOSE PEAK PERIODS IS
ACTUALLY CHEAPER AGAIN THEN
RUNNING BIG BASS LOAD GAS POWER
AT PEAK. SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CHECK THESE PRINCIPLES WHEN YOU
GO IT'S A TOUGH CONTEXT TO DO
IT IN AND I DO NOT FAULT IN ANY
WAY THE AUTHOR FOR FIGHTING FOR
HIS PEOPLE AND I'M TRYING TO DO
THE SAME SO. THAT'S WHY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMONSENSE MEASURE OF IT'S NOT
ONLY THAT SOLAR IS BEING OVER
PRODUCE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE PAIN STATES
LIKE NEVADA THE ODD TO TAKE
KERR OVERPRODUCED SOLAR THIS
ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS LOST THEIR
HOMES RECALLS A WHAT TO TRY TO
YOU WAS TO REPEAL IT AT A MORE
AFFORDABLE RATE WE DEAL WITH.
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE ON
A DAILY BASIS AND IT'S PROVEN
THAT ADDING SOLAR TO HOMES
BECAUSE IMPACT THE COSTS OF
HOMES I'VE TALKED TO DEVELOPERS
LIKE DOCTOR REALTORS IT DOES
INCREASE THE COST OF HOMES AND
WE CAN'T BUILD HOMES AS IT IS
AND WE'RE GOING TO ADD ANOTHER
BURDEN TO SOMEONE WAS LOST
THEIR HOMES. MAKES ABSOLUTELY
NO SENSE I ASKED FOR A VOTE.
CENTER GALGIANI. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WHILE MY DISTRICT
HAS NOT SUFFERED ANY FIRES MY
DISTRICT WAS GROUND ZERO FOR
THE FORECLOSURE CRISIS AND WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT AFFORDABILITY OF
HOMES IT'S NOT JUST WHAT THE
MONTHLY PAYMENT WILL BE FOR THE
HOME IT'S WHETHER OR NOT THE
BANK WILL UNDER RIGHT THE LOAN
AND ON A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR HOME. IF SOMEBODY AT A
FOUR HUNDRED AND- LET ME SEE IF
OF FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SOLAR
SYSTEM WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE
OF TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
ON A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR HOME. AND IF THE BANK
WON'T QUALIFY SOMEONE FOR A
LOAN YOU SIMPLY CAN'T GET THE
HOME. WHETHER YOU THINK YOU CAN
AFFORD IT OR NOT THE BANK
ASSEMBLY WILL NOT LOAN YOU THE
MONEY AND A TWO HUNDRED DOLLAR
A MONTH INCREASE IN A PAYMENT.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT FOR MANY
MANY FAMILIES AND FURTHERMORE
IF SOMEBODY HAS TO PUT A DOWN
PAYMENT THAT WOULD BE 20% THE
EQUIVALENT OF A SOLAR SYSTEM.
IF THAT SYSTEM WAS SAY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE IN CASH
FOR THE LOAN. AND WHEN
SOMEBODY'S REBUILDING THE
NUMBERS RIGHT NOT WILL END
MEMBERS WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD. MEMBERS ICE FOR
US STATED STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AS WELL AS SOMEBODY
THAT YOU KNOW A HUNDRED FIFTY
FOR MY NEIGHBORS LOST THEIR
HOMES YOUR THROUGHOUT MY ENTIRE
DISTRICT OVER SIX HUNDRED
PEOPLE LOST THEIR HOMES IT OVER
60% OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE UNDER
INSURED. THEY'RE UNDER INSURED
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO REBUILD
THEIR HOMES PROBABLY ANOTHER
20% OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
REBUILDING ANYWAY BECAUSE THEY
JUST CAN'T AFFORD. YANKEE CAN'T
CAN'T AFFORD THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE PAYMENTS GOING DOWN THE
LINE IN ANY OF THE OTHER THING
ABOUT THIS POLICY. YEAH WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO GET MORE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'RE WE'RE
SITTING POLICIES IN THIS IN
THIS BUILDING THIS CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE'VE
ALREADY ARE COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
IN NAPA COUNTY IN CINEMA COUNTY
WE'VE WE PASSED THE ORDINANCE
TO. COMPEL EVERY RESIDENT IN
THE COUNTY OF NAPA AND SADDAM
AND AS OTHERS HAVE. TO BELONG
TO A CCA. IT'S NOT OPT OUT YEAH
IT IS OPT OUT SO EVERYBODY IS
IN THE PROGRAM SO PRESUMABLY
THERE GETTING CLEAN ENERGY
ALREADY. AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT WERE FOR SEE THESE PEOPLE
TO PUT IN SOLAR IN THEIR HOMES
THIS IS A POLICY GONE AWRY I
CAN UNDERSTAND THE POLICY ABOUT
WANTING SO WE'RE- BUT IN THE
AREAS WHERE WE'RE ALREADY DOING
CCA'S. I THINK WE GET A RE
THINK YOUR WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE BUT MOREOVER MY BIG
CONCERN IS US TELLING
HOMEOWNERS IT'S HOMES HAVE JUST
BURNED TO THE GROUND THEY'VE
GOT NOTHING THEY'RE NOT COULD
BE ABLE TO READ THEIR- BRIE
BUILD THEIR HOMES. AND WERE
TELLING HIM WHAT THE BEST
INVESTMENT IS FOR THEM. WE'RE
TELLING THEM OF THE LEGISLATURE
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW THE
BETTER INVESTMENT IS FOR YOU TO
SPEND ANOTHER FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. ON YOUR HOME TO PUT
SOLAR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
RIDICULOUS I ASK FOR IN. A YES
VOTE. SENATOR SKINNER. HI THIS
IS JUST STUPID THINGS YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER. I HADN'T
PLANNED ON JOINING THIS DEBATE
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO WORK WERE SORT OF.
CONFLATING THINGS OR OR PUTTING
THINGS TOGETHER THAT AREN'T
REALLY PUT TOGETHER FOR EXAMPLE.
A HOME SOLAR INSTALLATION IS
NOT NECESSARILY SOMETHING THAT
WE A QUAKED WITH. ACHIEVING OUR
GREED WIDE RENEWABLE GOALS A
HOME SOLAR INSTALLATION IS
REALLY MUCH MORE LIKE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IT ALLOWS THAT HOME
TO DEAL WITH ITS ELECTRICITY
COSTS. AND JUST LIKE EFFICIENCY
MEASURES IT GREATLY REDUCES THE
NEED FOR DEPENDENCE ON
GENERATION EXTERNALLY. SO I
THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
FACTOR TO THINK ABOUT AND NOT
TO INTEGRATE IT WITH THE FACT
THAT GRID WIDE WE MAY BE.
PRODUCING FOR MORE THAN ENOUGH
SOLAR RESOURCE. WHICH WE I'LL
ALL OF WE CAN DISCUSS ANOTHER
TIME ALL THE DIFFERENT WAYS WE
COULD USE THAT STROLLER
RESOURCE AND THAT OUR AGENCIES
ARE ACTUALLY PLANNING FOR BUT
THE FIRST THING I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT TO CONFLATE
IT WITH THE GRID WIDE RESOURCES
NOT APPROPRIATE. SECONDARILY ON
THE MORTGAGE ISSUE. THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE EITHER RE FIGHTER
HOMES OR GOTTEN ALONE RECENTLY
FOR OUR HOMES WE KNOW THAT. B.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE LANDER
FACTORS IS WHAT ARE YOUR
MONTHLY COSTS AND WHAT YOUR
INCOMING CAN YOU COVER THOSE
MONTHLY COSTS. IN THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVE A SOLAR SYSTEM REDUCES
YOUR MONTHLY COSTS SOME OF THE
US IN THE WHEN THE FORMULATION.
OF WHAT IT IS YOU CAN AFFORD
FOR A LOAN. YOU CAN AFFORD A
LARGER LOAN. AND THIS IS A
STANDARD PRACTICE OF LENDERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE NOT ONLY
PURCHASED A HOUSE WITH THE
SOLAR SYSTEM BUT I ALSO RE
FIGHT IT. AND THE LENDER. WE
WAS FIFTH AFTER THOSE QUESTIONS
AND THEY WERE ASKED THEY WERE
ASKED IN THE- QUESTIONNAIRE
THAT I HAD TO PREPARE. FINALLY
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO REALIZE THAT SOLAR SYSTEMS
OUR FORM OF HOME HARDENING. NO
CERTAINLY SOLAR SYSTEM DOES NOT
PREVENT THE HOUSE FROM BEING
FROM GOING INTO FLAMES WHEN WE
HAVE A CONFLAGRATION AS WE'VE
HAD IN THE TUBS FIRE IN
PARADISE BUT- WHEN WE DE
COMMISSION OUR GRID TO PREVENT
A FIRE. THAT SYSTEM WHICH NOW
COMMONLY IS COMBINED WITH.
STORAGE ALLOWS THAT FACILITY TO
STILL HAVE ELECTRICITY. WHICH
AS OUR POPULATION IS OLDER AND
MORE OF US WILL BE POTENTIALLY
RELYING ON THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO PLUG IN TO KEEP US ALIVE
WE'RE GOING TO WANT THAT AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS MORE
AND MORE OWNERS BUYING DIESEL
GENERATORS. OUR MIND IS THAT
DIESEL. POLLUTION IS ONE OF THE
MOST HEALTH HARMING POLLUTION'S
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR STATE WE DO
NOT NEED TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
BUY MORE DIESEL GENERATORS SO
WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
MOTIVATION OF. TRYING TO ASSIST
OUR. OWNERS THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR HOMES I DON'T THINK THIS
IS AN APPROPRIATE FIX IT ALSO
DOES NOT ADDRESS. THE PROBLEM
OF WHAT OUR INSURANCE. INDUSTRY
IS DOING TO OUR HOMEOWNERS
WHICH IS A SEPARATE ISSUE WHICH
I KNOW ALL OF US WANT TO ENGAGE
IN AND TRY TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
WE KNOW THE THREAT TO HOME
OWNERSHIP IF YOU CANNOT GET
INSURANCE FOR YOUR HOME. SO
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. SENATOR GLACIER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
AYE AYE I JOIN IN APPRECIATING
THE THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY ON THIS ISSUE AND I KNOW
THAT FOR OR AGAINST THIS
MEASURE THAT TO ALL OF US ARE
BIG PROPONENTS OF SOLAR ENERGY
AND CLEAN CLEAN ENERGY BUT I
THINK THE ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE ENCOUNTER ON THIS FLOOR
QUITE OFTEN IS THE VIEW THAT A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR ALL OF
US. FOR ALL OF OUR PEOPLE AND
OUR STATE. AND YOU KNOW IT.
HAVE A SOME OF US HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO UP TO
PARADISE SEE THIS INCREDIBLE
DESTRUCTION. THAT OCCURRED
THERE AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU SEE QUITE CLEARLY. AS
YOU TRAVEL THROUGH THAT THAT
DEVASTATED TOWN IS THAT. SOME
HOMES SURVIVE IN SOME HOMES
DIDN'T BUT IT'S A HEAVILY
FORESTED AREA. AND THAT THE
VIEW IS IF WE WERE SELLING
SOLAR HERE ON THE FLOOR OF
HOUSE SOMETHING PAYS FOR ITSELF.
WELL THERE'S GENERALIZATIONS
WITHIN THAT CATEGORY IT'S
SIMPLY A GENERALIZATION. AND IF
YOU HAVE A HOUSE IN PARADISE
THAT HAS BEEN BURNED DOWN BUT
IT'S STILL SURROUNDED HEAVILY
SURROUNDED BY FORESTED LAND. I
DON'T THINK YEAH IF YOU'RE
SELLING THAT PERSON SOLAR. THAT
DOESN'T GET THE LIGHT OF DAY ON
THEIR HOME VERY OFTEN THAT THAT
GENERALIZATION REALLY APPLY.
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR US OFTEN HERE. IS
IT A MANDATE SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY HEALTHY GREAT COMPELLING
NEED AND CERTAINLY ON THE ISSUE
OF SOLAR THERE'S GREAT
ARGUMENTS FOR IT. BUT THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN HEARD.
AND THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY
DESERVE TO MAKE A JUDGMENT
ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS RIGHT FOR
THEM WITH THE COST UP FRONT CAN
BE BORNE OUT BY THE BENEFITS
LONG TERM WHETHER IT'S IN A
LOWER UTILITY BILL OR WHAT HAVE
YOU. AND SHOULD WE AND THAT
TIME OF NEED A BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT CHOICE AND THAT'S WHY I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
SENATOR JACKSON. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SITE
JOINT MY COLLEAGUES IN A
ANGUISHING A LITTLE BIT OVER
THIS DEBATE I'VE SOLAR MY HOME
MY ENERGY BILLS COME TO ABOUT
ELEVEN DOLLARS A MONTH TEN
DOLLARS OF THAT IS THE
TRANSMISSION CHARGE I HAVE TO
PAY I APPRECIATE OF THE
BENEFITS OF SOLAR I HAVE A
SOLAR DRIVEN CAR SO I'M A BIG
PROPONENT OF SOLAR AND I THINK
THAT IT IS THE FUTURE. AND I
SUPPORTED HEAVILY. BUT I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT. THE LIKE
OF MY GOOD FRIEND FROM NAPA AND
IN OTHERS INDICATE WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE HUMAN PART OF THIS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
PEOPLE I KNOW. WHO CANNOT
REBUILD THEIR HOMES. OR ARE
STILL A YEAR AND A HALF LATER
NOT TRUST A WILDFIRE BUT A
SUBSEQUENT DEBRIS FLOW WHICH
WAS INDEED A NATURAL DISASTER
THE TOOK OUT 10% OF THE
COMMUNITY OF MONT TO SEED. THE
KILL TWENTY THREE P. I LOW END
AND IT'S AN AREA I DRIVE
THROUGH EVERY TIME I COME HOME
FROM SACRAMENTO I AM REMINDED
OF IT CONSTANTLY AND I
PERSONALLY DID NOT SUFFER BUT I
CAN'T TELL YOU. THE EMOTIONAL.
TRAUMA ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
EXPERIENCE LET ALONE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF YOU CAN REBUILD
YOUR HOME. AND IF THE INSURANCE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET IS
EVEN ADEQUATE TO DO THE ACT.
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE ARE UNDER
INSURED. THE DISCUSSION WE'RE
HAVING ABOUT OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE WILDFIRES IN CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ITS IMPACT IN THE STATE ARE
ALL VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY
RELEVANT AND THOSE ARE
DISCUSSIONS WHETHER IT'S ABOUT
INSURANCE WHETHER IT'S ABOUT
HOME HARDENING WHETHER IT'S
ABOUT HOW WE DEVELOP OUR
COMMUNITIES. PROACTIVELY IT
RETRO EXPECTEDLY THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS. BUT AS
I'VE LISTENED TO THIS
DISCUSSION I AM HEARING MY
CONSTITUENTS MY FRIENDS WHO ARE
ABSOLUTELY AGONIZING OVER WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO LIVE. WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE GOING TO EVEN
BE ABLE TO REBUILD SOME
SEMBLANCE OF THE HOMES THAT
THEY HAD. AND I AGREE THAT I
DON'T THINK WE CAN DECIDE HERE
IN THIS LEGISLATURE WHAT THESE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE DOING WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT A HUGE NUMBER
OF HOMES EXCEPT IN PARADISE WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT MANY HOMES. I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS GOING TO
UNDERMINE OUR SOLAR PROGRAM. IF
WE IF WE OF PASSES LEGISLATION
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THE HUMANITY OF THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM
THIS. AND THE NOTION OF AN
ADDITIONAL WHETHER IT'S TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT IN A FEW
YEARS IT WILL SAVE THE MONEY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT NOW I THINK WE
HAVE TO HELP THESE PEOPLE IN
EVERY WAY WE CAN. TO TRY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AFTER THIS
MOST TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE THAT
THEY HAVE SUFFERED AND SO IT IS
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND
CONTINUE TO WORK MY WITH MY
FRIENDS IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. TO TRY TO DO MORE TO
CREATE ALTERNATIVE ENERGY BUT
THIS IS NOT THE BILL TO DO IT.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. SENATOR RICE OF.
MADAM PRESIDENT OF FIRST OF ALL
I WANNA CLARIFY THAT MY INITIAL
COMMENTS WERE SIMPLY TO ROAST
SENATOR DOLLY BECAUSE THIS IS
HIS FIRST BILL AS A CENTER AND
I CAN SEE HOW THAT WENT REALLY
AWRY. AND I'D LIKE ALL THE
GIANTS FOR THAT. BUT I'D LIKE
TO PUT ON THE RECORD MY
COMMENTS RELATED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY ABOUT
AND WHY WE NEED TO PASS IT
TODAY. THIS BILL IS NOT GOING
TO SLOW DOWN CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVING IN. ITS GOT GAS
REDUCTION GOALS AND GREEN IN
THE GRID THIS IS NOT THE BILL
THAT WILL ACCOMPLISH THAT.
SIMPLY SPEAKING IN RIGHT NOW
THE URGENCY IS REPLACING THIS
HOUSING GETTING PEOPLE BACK IN
THEIR HOMES. AS THEIR HOMES
WERE WHEN THEY LOST THEM AND IF
THEY ELECT TO ADD SOLAR THROUGH
THE CONSTRUCTION PROCESS LET
THAT BE THEIR CHOICE BUT NOT
LET USNOT MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT AND GETTING THEM BACK
INTO THEIR HOMES. MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES WILL PROBABLY NOT
REBUILD THEIR HOMES MANY OF
THEM WILL HAVE A HARD TIME.
GETTING THE FULL VALUE FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES OF THEIR
HOME SO THEY CAN FULLY REPLACE
THEM WITHOUT HAVING OUT OF
POCKET COSTS IF A HOME DOESN'T
HAVE SOLAR NOW YOU'RE HAVE AT
IT BELIEVE ME THERE'S GOING TO
BE A COST. AND THERE IS GONNA
BE. PERMIT PROCESS TO DO THAT
AND I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
FAIR THAT WE PUT THIS
REQUIREMENT ON VICTIMS OF FIRES
THIS IS A COMPASSIONATE BILL.
YOUR POSITION TODAY IS WHETHER
YOU HAVE COMPASSION FOR THESE
PEOPLE THEY'RE SUFFERING OR NOT.
THAT THAT I REALLY WHAT THIS
MATTERS ABOUT MY HOPE AS A
LEGISLATURE WE STAND BY THE
VICTIMS AND WE DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN TO GET HIM BACK IN
THEIR HOMES AND I ASKED FOR NAY
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SENATOR RUBIO. I'M I GUESS MY
COMMENTS ARE MORE. CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH OUR GREAT SENATOR
FROM SANTA BARBARA AND SAN
DIEGO I WAS IN THE COMMITTEE
WHO SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE AND
I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS
WHO'VE ALREADY OVERSTRESSED
WORRIED CONCERNED THERE'S SO
MUCH THAT GOES INTO FIGURING
OUT WHAT HAPPENS AFTER A
TRAGEDY AND I DO. YOU DON'T
WANT TO MAKE NOTIFIED THE
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
EVERYTHING IS VALID IN TERMS OF
LONG TERM BENEFITS ARE
RESILIENCY BUT IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE WHEN I LOOK
AT THE AT THE MEASURE AND I
BELIEVE THERE'S A SUNSET DATE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IT WILL
ALLOW THESE FOLKS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO REBUILD. AT LEAST
THOSE FIFTY YEARS TO GET BACK
ON THEIR FEET SO I WOULD ASK
THAT WE THINK OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO REBUILD.
AND I ALSO ASK FOR YOUR APPLE
THANK YOU. SENATE ON. THANK YOU
AND PRESIDENT IN AND COLLEAGUES
IN FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY HOW
MUCH I RESPECT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU AND YOUR YOUR
CONCERNS OVER THE BILL AND
CERTAINLY OVER THOSE PEOPLE
THAT OF. PRETTY MUCH LOST
EVERYTHING. I'M I'VE ALWAYS
CONSIDERED MYSELF KIND OF A
GREEN REPUBLICAN COMING FROM
PROBABLY. THE MOST GREEN COUNTY
IN THE STATE IN IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY WE HAVE. GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY WE HAVE STORAGE WE HAVE
SOLAR. WE DON'T HAVE HYDRO WE
DON'T HAVE AND NEAR ANY BIG
LAKES. I HELD MY HOME AND I'VE
ONLY THREE ELECTRIC CARS I'VE
DONE MY PART. TO GET THE STATE
ON TRACK TO GETTING TO THE
POINT WHERE WE REACH OUR GOALS
AND I'M VERY PROUD ACTUALLY OF
THE STATE BECAUSE WE PROBABLY
COME FURTHER TO UTILIZING
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY GOOD CLEAN
ENERGY THE PROBABLY ANY OTHER
STATE OR MAYBE ANY OTHER
COUNTRY. ON THE PLANET. BUT YOU
KNOW OUR HOMES ARE OUR HEAVEN
ON EARTH AND A LOT OF FOLKS
LOST EVERYTHING NOT ONLY DID
THEY LOSE THEIR HOMES. FOR MANY
THEY LOST THEIR JOBS THEY LOST
THEIR KIDS LOST THEIR SCHOOLS
THEY HAD TO GO AND OTHER
SCHOOLS AND HAVE THE TRAUMA OF
YOU KNOW MAKING NEW FRIENDS ALL
OVER AGAIN. AND CERTAINLY BUT
THE SHORTAGE OF HOUSING THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE SEE IN THE COST OF MATERIALS
RISE. WE PROBABLY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH CONTRACTORS TO QUICKLY
BUILD ALL THE HOMES THAT WERE
LOST. SO MANY OF A SHORTAGE OF
THINGS OF COURSE COSTS INCREASE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT FOR
SOME OF YOU MAY BE YOUR HOBBIES
OR GOLF OR TENNIS MY HOBBY
ACTUALLY IS REAL ESTATE I BUY A
LOT OF REAL ESTATE. I SAW A LOT
OF REAL ESTATE. AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT. PUTTING PANELS ON A
HOME. IS A UP FRONT COST.
PROSPECTIVELY IF YOU PUT PANELS
ON YOU'RE GOING TO SAVE MONEY
AND MAYBE EVEN REDUCING THE
COST OF THOSE SOLAR PANELS OVER
TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS. BUT TODAY
WHEN. MOST OF THESE VICTIMS ARE
UNDER INSURED THEY HAVE TO FIND
ALTERNATIVE FINANCING TO. GET
THEIR HOMES REBUILT AGAIN. AND
THE BANKS ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE
A DECISION ON WHETHER OR NOT
THERE UTILITY PRICES ARE GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT LESS IN THE
FUTURE. THEY'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT YOUR INCOME. AND
YOUR INCOME MATCH WHAT YOUR
EXPENSES ARE GOING TO BE WITH
RESPECT YOUR MORTGAGE ON YOUR
NEW. HOME THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE DETERMINING FACTOR. SO I
ALSO DON'T GET A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
WITH 1100% OF WHAT YOU SAID ON
THIS BILL. AND SO I HAD TO TAKE
OPPORTUNITY STAND UP BECAUSE I
THINK SHE SPOKE WITH A LOT OF
WISDOM I THINK SHE SPOKE WITH A
LOT OF COMPASSION AND I'M PROUD
TO JOIN HER. IN URGING ALL OF
YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
COMPASSIONATE BILL. TO HELP
THESE PEOPLE OUT. OUR DR
ALREADY BE ONE SEVENTY THANK
YOU. SEC CENTER STERN. YEAH I
KNOW I AYE AYE RARELY SPEAKING
I'M SPEAKING TWICE I JUST WANNA
GET SOME FACTS IN THE RECORD
JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR. EXEMPTIONS
EXIST UNDER CURRENT LAW. IF
YOU'RE IN A HEAVILY SHADED AREA
WITH TREES SO MOST OF PARADISE
WILL BE EXEMPT UNDER CURRENT
LAW. IF THEIR SHADE YOUR EXAMS.
IF THEE AND THIS IS ON YOUR
ANNOUNCES HOMES THAT ARE SHADED
BY TREES HILLS OR OTHER
STRUCTURES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
INSTALL SOLAR HOMEOWNERS IN
AREAS WITH COMMUNITY SOLAR
PROGRAMS LIKE A CC A WHERE THEY
HAVE COMMUNITY SOLAR ARE ALSO
EXEMPT SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT HOW THE CURRENT LAW
WORKS. I JUST DON'T WANT TO.
OVER INFLATE WHAT BUILDING
CODES GONNA DO THERE ARE A LOT
OF WAYS TO ACCOMMODATE RIGHT
NOW RESPECT THE AUTHOR AND ALL
THE ENTHUSIASM HERE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE VICTIMS OF THE
WALLS THE FIRE AND PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY I WANT TO GIVE THEM A
CHANCE TO ENJOY THESE BENEFITS
TOO SO I'LL BE VOTING NO. THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION EIGHT.
CENTER DAHLE YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR HEALTHY
DEBATE I WANT TO START OFF WITH
SOMETHING A LITTLE LIGHT BEFORE
I GET SERIOUS SOME I HOPE
NOBODY HAD A BAD PEACH
YESTERDAY AND I ALSO MAYBE
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY ELSE TO
JOCKEY MY BILLS WHEN THEY GET
OVER HERE FROM THE ASSEMBLY. SO
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO. IN
OUR MY DISTRICT I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER HERE WATCH
THIS BILL CLOSELY BECAUSE IT.
EFFECTS PEOPLE WHO WE'VE LOOKED
IN THE AYE WHO ARE TRYING TO
REBUILD THEIR HOMES. THIS ISN'T
THIS ISN'T. THIS ISN'T A DEBATE
ABOUT SOLAR WHETHER WE SHOULD
HAVE IT OR NOT HAVE IT ON A
HOMES IS DEBATE ABOUT. GETTING
PEOPLE WHO'VE LOST EVERYTHING.
BACK IN A HOME AND IS
REBUILDING THEIR LIVES. I
NARROW THIS BILL DOWN IT
SUNSETS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO THEY
ONLY HAVE IF THEY CAN EVEN GET
A BUILDING PERMIT BY THEN TO
REBUILD THEIR OWN. GOD HELP ON.
AND IF YOU BUILD A HOME IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS OUR BUILDING STANDARDS
ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
THROUGH AT THE LOCAL LEVELS AND
IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE. AND MOST
THESE OR UNDER INSURED. THIS IS
NOT A DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD HAVE SOUL OR NOT OR
WHETHER BIOMASS VERSES WHATEVER
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO ENGAGE
IN THOSE DEBATES AND MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT I'VE CHAMPION A
LOTOF LEGISLATION ON BIOMASS
AND FORESTRY AND CARBON OUTPUT
FROM FIRES. THAT IS THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THAT. THIS IS NOT ABOUT
UTILITIES THIS IS NOT ABOUT
INSURANCE THIS IS ABOUT
ALLOWING SOMEBODY TO. EITHER.
NOT PUT SOLAR ON THEIR HOME IF
THEY WANT TO THEY CAN. AND YES
THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS IN THE
SOLAR FEW HAVE SHADE IN THOSE
THINGS YES THOSE ARE THERE BUT
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO. ARE
TRYING TO GET BACK IN THEIR
HOMES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DEBATE. ON THOSE OTHER ISSUES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY
THIS BILL SUNSETS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. ASK FOR BUT I VOTE ON
AB ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BATES HI BILL HI PORGES. I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG BY
DAILY. I DODD BY THE RAZA. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH I HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO I. MURTADA HI JACKSON
FIGHT JONES LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL. MONNING HI MORE
LOCK. I'M A REAL BY NELSON. I
OPINION BY PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN NO
STONE. I AM BURKE. IA CATHY NO
WIENER NO WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN NO.
ATKINS JONES MITCHELL SKINNER.
ICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO. HOUSEKEEPING UPDATE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP THREE MORE
BILLS ANIMAL MORAL WE WILL MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
AND THEN NOT SPUR PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR AND THEN BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
WE'RE GONNA BE DONE. BY ELEVEN
SO MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY ONE. I
SENATOR NIELSEN. AND DINNER
DURING MEALS. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR NIELSEN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. BETTER
PRESERVATION OF THE SENATE I'M
DELIGHTED TO BE ABLE TO CARRY
THIS BILL. AND ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB FIVE OH FOUR. IT
CLARIFIES RESIDENCY.
CONFIRMATION PROCEDURES THE
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIAL HAVE
TO FOLLOW. ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA LAWS CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. CURRENTLY
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW REQUIRE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO CONDUCT
PERIODIC RESIDENCY CONFIRMATION
PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF A VOTING. AN
ELIGIBILITY. THE VERIFY THE
ADDRESSES. OF THE REGISTERED
VOTERS. WHEN. THIS SURVEY WAS
TAKEN SOMETIMES PEOPLE HAVE
MOVED. REGISTRATION IS COME ON
ACTIVE. AND EVENTUALLY EVEN
CANCEL. THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
CONSISTENT APPLICATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WOULD BE
IN EFFECT. AND THESE
UNNECESSARY CANCELLATIONS WOULD
NOT OCCUR. HE EXPANDS THE TOOLS
IN THE TOOLBOX TO USE THE USED
TO CONFIRM. REGISTRATION. AND
THE ELIGIBILITY VOTERS SELECT
TO THE RESIDENCY. THE PROMOTER
SPREAD ALLOWS THE VOTERS. TO
USE A SECRETARY STATES MY VOTER
STATUS WEBSITE TO CONFIRM THE
RESIDENCY. SO THEY HAVE A PLACE
TO GO. TO BE SURE. IT'S
SPONSORED BY SECRETARY STATE
ALEX PADILLA. HAS SUPPORT OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND
DISABILITY RIGHTS. OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO OPPOSITION. IT WOULD ENSURE
INTEGRITY ENHANCE THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR VOTING. I WOULD ASK AND
I WILL. SIR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SING NINE
BOB THIS IS LIKE A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NONE.
THIRTY EIGHT ICE. NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THREE.
SENATOR ROBB MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SOME OF THE
ELEVEN OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON AND ACT REALLY
INTO INSURANCE. CENTER OFF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB ELEVEN OH FOUR
MAKES TO CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE GUARANTEE FUND.
PROVISIONS FIRST THE BILL AS TO
PUBLIC MEMBERS TO THE BOARD OF
THAT ASSOCIATION CURRENT LAW
ESTABLISHES THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WHICH IS COMPRISED
SOLELY OF INSURERS THIS BILL
WERE IT WILL ENSURE THE PUBLIC
VOICE IS NOW PART OF THE DEAL
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS. SECOND
THE BILL CREATES AN ASSESSMENT
TO FUND FNANCIAL OVERSIGHT OF
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
COMPANIES. UNDER EARLIER BILL
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO CONDUCT.
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT
OF LONG TERM CARE INSURERS.
THIS BILL AND THE ASSESSMENT
WILL FACILITATE THE PROCESS THE
ASSESSMENT IMPORTANTLY WAS
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE INDUSTRY
AND THE DEPARTMENT AND ENJOYS
SUPPORT FROM BOTH I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS I A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NONE. ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE.
SENATOR STERN. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN AND ACT REALLY INTO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCE FOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB THREE OH FIVE
AUTHORED BY MY SIMPLY COLLEAGUE
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF A PRIOR
BILL AB EIGHT FIFTY FROM TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY SIX
ENACT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT
PRIOR MEASURE AMENDED THE JOINT
POWERS ACT TO ALLOW MUNICIPAL
WATER UTILITIES TO ISSUE. A
RATE REDUCTION BONDS FOR WATER
CAPITAL PROJECTS FOR GROUND
WATER CLEAN UP THIS BILL WILL
NOT JUST ADDRESS GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP BUT ALSO ALSO ALLOW FOR
THOSE RATE REDUCTION ONDS TO
BE ISSUED FOR WOULD REDUCE OF
WASTE WATER PROJECT THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AS WE TRY TO IMPROVE
OUR EFFICIENCY AND WATER
CONSERVATION THE BILLING SYSTEM
HOWEVER A D. W. P. SOME OF YOU
MAY KNOW IS TAKEN SOME YEARS TO
GET BACK ON TRACK AND WAS NOT
READY IN TIME FOR THE SUNSET
DATE DOES THIS BILL WOULD. GIVE
THEM FIVE MORE YEARS TO GET
THAT DONE AND ALLOW FOR THOSE
QUALIFIED PROJECTS TO INCLUDE
WASTE WATER SYSTEMS UNANIMOUS.
SUPPORT NO RIGHT AFTER THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS
ALSO IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SING NINE THIRTY
EIGHT I. ZERO KNOWS THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS THERE ANY ITEM
MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OR IS THERE ANY ITEM
THAT THEY SHOULD BE PULLED.
SEEING NONE MISTER MISTER
SECRETARY. HE KNEW. TO RETRACT
THAT THERE IS AN ITEM TO BE
PULLED. SENATOR ALLEN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MR
MAJORITY LEADER AND WEBER. WANT
TO ASK THAT WE REMOVE FROM
SPECIAL CONSENT ITEM TWO SEVEN
SEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. SO ORDERED. IS IT. OKAY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ALL ITEMS ON THE CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL 789-140-1140 THREE
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN SIX SEVENTY
ONE SINKER RESOLUTION TWENTY
NINE SENATE BILL. ONE TWENTY
NINE TO FIFTY NINE TO SEVENTY
ONE FOR NINETY SIX FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN EIGH BILL. SIXTEEN FIFTY
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN OH THREE
THREE OH NINE TE FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO FOUR
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE HUNDRED ONE OH
FOUR ONE OF SIX AND SOMEBODY
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE ELEVEN.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO ITEMS AND LEFT THE CALL.
THE FIRST ITEM IS FILE NUMBER
FIFTEEN. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. OUR OUR PLEASE
CALL BACK CALL THE ROLL I'M
SORRY. CALL THE ABSENTEES DELHI
TADA BY JONES MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. ICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS
THREE THE APARTMENT IS
CONCERNED CONFIRMED. ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN THAT APPOINTMENT
AS WELL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
TITLE. BY JONES. ITEM AYE AYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. AND
OUR ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE. TADO BY GROW BY JONES.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. SEC
. WE ARE ON
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
PENN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS SPEAKING AND WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW OR MAY HAVE HEARD
YESTERDAY I WAS PHYSICALLY
ASSAULTED AS I WAS WALKING FROM
THE CAPITAL TO AN EVENT AND I
ALSO WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THE PRESS
TERM AND THE MINORITY LEADER
AND MANY OF YOU HERE WHO HAVE
EXPRESSED YOUR BOTH PERSONAL
AND PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR ME AND
THE COMBINATION OF THE ASSAULT
ON YESTERDAY. CERTAINLY IT'S
ONLY THROUGH CIVIL DEBATE. GOOD
POLICY FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER I NEED TO MAKE A NOTE
THAT YESTERDAY'S ASSAULT IS NOT
SIMPLY THE ACT OF A LONE
EXTREMIST. THIS IS THE EXPECTED
OUTCOME OF THREATENING AND
VIOLENT RHETORIC BY THE ANTI
VACCINE MOVEMENT. MY ASSAILANT
THIS PROUD OF HIS VIOLENT
ATTACKED IN FACT HE POSTED ON
FACEBOOK FOR HIS OWN BENEFIT TO
THE ISOLATION OF MANY OF HIS
FOLLOWERS. AND AS IN THE VICTIM
OF THAT I DID ASK FACEBOOK
YESTERDAY TO TAKE IT DOWN. BUT
THEY HAVE REFUSED NOT VIOLENT
ENOUGH. FACEBOOK IS
DELIBERATELY GIVING A PLATFORM
TO HIS VIOLENCE AND PERHAPS
INCITING OF ANOTHER PERSON
TUESDAY TO DO THE SAME EIGHTY
ONE UP THE ANTE. BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO THINK ABOUT WHY WHY MY
SENATE SO JUSTIFIED TO
PHYSICALLY ATTACKED ME
YESTERDAY. AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE OPPONENTS OF MY BILL SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX HAVE REPEATEDLY
USED. AND CONDONE VIOLENT
RHETORIC AND IMAGERY JUST THE
FINE BY. SO VICTIM BUT. MANY IF
YOU AND YOUR OFFICES YOUR STAFF
HAVE EXPERIENCED SOME OF THIS
ALREADY BOTH OF THOSE OF YOU
ARE HERE FOR SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
AND ALSO ONE SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
CAME THROUGH THIS CHAMBER IN
FACT IN TWO SEVEN SEVEN WE'VE
HAD SOME MEMBERS WHO ACTUALLY
EVEN HAVE TO CLOSE OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES BECAUSE THE NATURE OF
THE THREATS. TO THE STAFF. MORE
RECENTLY. OUR STATE JUNIOR WHO
OPPOSES THE BILL CAME TO THE
CAPITOL. CALLED VACCINES
HOLOCAUST PREVIOUSLY COMPARED
MY BILL. TO THE JEWS BEING PUT
TOGETHER US DURING WORLD WAR
TWO. WELL IN THE MEANTIME THE
END OF ACCESS POSTS MEMES OF ME
IS LAWYER AND DOCTOR MANGEL A
AND YOU WONDER WHY. YOU WONDER
WHY SOMEONE WOULD BE INCITED TO
COMMIT VIOLENCE. THE RALLY IN
FRONT OF OUR BUILDING HERE AND
WHAT DID THEY HAVE BEFORE THEM
IN THE RALLY A PICTURE. A
POSTER WITH A DRY MY FACE
SPLATTERED WITH WHAT APPEARED
TO BE BLOOD. AND THEN THEY
WALKED INTO THE HEARING ROOM IN
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS ASSEMBLY
HEARING HEALTH HEARING ROOM
WEARING T. SHIRTS WITH THIS
IMAGE. AND YOU WONDER WHY
SOMEONE DECIDES TO ACTUALLY
CARRY OUT MISSILES. THEY MAILED
BRICKS THROUGH THE FAMILY
MEMBERS. AND IN FACT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE A RALLY IN AUGUST
TWENTY EIGHTH AND I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
DO BUT I'VE HEARD THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE COMING IN WEARING
GUY. FAWKES MASK. NOW FOR THOSE
OF YOU DON'T KNOW HISTORY GUY
FAWKES WAS A MAN WHO. THREATEN
THE TERRORIST ATTACK ON A
LEGISLATIVE BODY THE PARLIAMENT.
SO THINK ABOUT IT THEY WANT TO
COME. TO OUR STATE CAPITOL THE
STATE CAPITOL CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE MEET YOU'RE NOT CHAMBERS.
DRESSED UP AS SOMEONE WHO
WISHES TO COMMIT A TERRORIST
ATTACK ON A LEGISLATURE
ALLEGEDLY BODY. THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY WHAT I'M HERE TO SAY.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT NEARLY THE ONE
ACTOR THE ONE PERSON WHO
ASSAILED YESTERDAY THAT WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT. IT'S THIS
BROADER. ACCEPTANCE OR
TOLERANCE OF THIS KIND OF
VIOLENT RHETORIC ONE THAT'S
GIVEN A PLATFORM BY SOCIAL
MEDIA OTHERS. THIS NEEDS TO
STOP. IT'S NO SURPRISE. THAT
THERE WAS A PHYSICAL ASSAULT
AND WHO KNOWS WHAT THE NEXT ONE
WILL BE BUT THIS DOES NEED TO
STOP AND I DO WANT TO THANK.
ALL OF YOU AND MADE YOU SPOKEN
OUT AND SAID WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT CIVILLY WE HAVE
DIFFERENCES. AND WE NEED TO
DEBATE THOSE DIFFERENCES. AND
DEAL WE MADE WE'RE NOT ALL
GOING TO AGREE. BUT WE CAN DO
IT CIVILLY. WE CAN DO IT
PASSIONATELY BUT WE DON'T NEED
TO THREATEN FULLY. AND COULD
AND. BASICALLY COMMITTEE YEAH
SUGGEST VIOLENCE AND HAVE
SOMEONE HOPE SOMEONE CARRIES IT
OUT AND SO WITH THAT I DO WANNA
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I THINK AS WE MOVED
TOGETHER WE ARE GOING TO WORK-TOGETHER FOR BETTER CALIFORNIA
BUT WE ALSO I HOPE WE CAN CALL
ON PEOPLE. JOINTLY TOGETHER. TO
SAY NO MORE THIS KIND OF
RHETORIC NEEDS TO STOP. YOU
MAKE YOUR ARGUMENTS BUT DON'T
THREATEN EE NO BY THANK YOU
.
STILL UNDER PROVISIONS OF THE
OF THE FLOOR CENTER NIELSEN.
THAT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE AND.
BLASTING COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO. YOU AYE DELIGHT IN
SERVING WITH THE TWO GENTLEMEN.
PROJECT YOUR SHELVES INTO HIS
SHOESAND WHAT THAT MUST OF
FELT LIKE. NOW THROUGH THE
COURSE OF THIS DISCUSSION OF
THE BILL. THEN HE AND I MAY
HAVE AT DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON
THE BILL. BUT THE BUILD UP AS
THE BILL MOVED ALONG THERE WAS
A CONTINUING ESCALATION. OF
THIS INTIMIDATION. WHY I FELT
COMPELLED TO. TOO LITTLE TOO TO
MY OWN YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS
NONSENSE. THIS NONSENSE NO I
TAKE IT TO ANOTHER LEVEL OF
NONSENSE. AND IT CERTAINLY IS
NOT HOW WE DO. THE BUSINESS OF
GOVERNMENT IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THIS PHENOMENA HAS AFFECTED
THE WHOLE NATION. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR CAMPUSES
MANY GROUPS FROM ALL
PERSUASIONS. ARE COMING ON NOW
AND STANDING FOURTH. AND
THREATENING AND INTIMIDATING
INCOMING DISGUISED. SOON I WILL
THEIR WORK THEY DON'T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE. THEY'RE EVEN ASHAMED
TO SHOW THEIR FACES. SO HOW
CONVICTED ARE THEY TO THEIR
PASSION WHATEVER THAT MAY BE.
BUT IF WE AS A SOCIETY AS
INDIVIDUALS NOT JUST ELECTED
OFFICIALS WITH THE BURDEN IS
GREAER ON US BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A BULLY PULPIT TO SPEAK
OUT. AND WE MUST DO SHOW. NO
LOS. NO ONE'S. AND WE CONDEMN.
AND WE'RE NOT ENCOURAGING. AND
TURN OUR BACKS AND SAY WELL
THAT HAPPENED SOMEWHERE ELSE.
NOT A BIG DEAL OR I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. WE
CARE ABOUT THE FREE EXPRESSION
OF OPINIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE OF
THE STATE SENATE. WERE RESPECT
FOR THE INSTITUTION AS RULES
FOR EACH OTHER WHAT WE CALL
SENATORIAL COURTESY PREVAIL. IT
IS THE INVISIBLE HAND THAT
GUIDES US. IN ORDER LIBERTY
PROCESS SEES HERE. I FELT FOR
MY COLLEAGUE. PRAYED FOR HIM.
BECAUSE THIS CAN BE RATHER
DRAMATIC. IN OTHER PARTS OF MY
LIFE I'VE HAD TO WORRY A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT. PERSONAL THREATS.
NOT FUN. IT CAUSES GREAT
CONCERN TO YOUR FAMILIES. ARE
THEY NEXT. YOUR HOME BE VISITED
YES OUR HOMES HAVE BEEN VISITED
ACROSS THE LAND. BY THESE
VARIOUS GROUPS WITH THEIR
VARIOUS A GENESIS. HAVE YOUR
AGENDA. BUT WORK YOUR OPINIONS
THROUGH THE SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE THAT WE ENJOY IN
THIS LAND. PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS YOURSELF.
IN CIVIL AND SAFE WASTE. WE
MUST SPEAK OUT. CENTER PAN KNOW
THAT OUR HEARTS ARE WITH YOU
AND THAT WE WILL JOIN YOU IN
WHATEVER OUR- PUBLIC DISCOURSE
IS NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO.
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE. MOVING ON THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM UP
PRESIDENT. ON A LIGHTER AND
MORE EXCITING NOTE THOUGH
DOCTOR PANEL YOU KNOW THAT I
HAVE YOUR BACK AND SO DOES
EVERYONE ELSE HERE BECAUSE THAT
IS JUST UNACCEPTABLE WITH THAT
PEOPLE THINK THAT'S THE WAY TO
EXPRESS THAT THEY DON'T LIKE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WE'VE GOT YOU
BUT ON A LIGHTER AND MORE
EXCITING NOTE I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK ALL OF THE WOMEN OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND
OUR GENTLEMAN TO JOIN US ON
MONDAY AND WEAR WHITE TUESDAY
IS THE NINETY NINTH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT OF
THE WOMAN'S RIGHT TO VOTE BUT
WE WON'T BE ON THE FLOOR ON
TUESDAY SO IF YOU CAN WEAR
WHITE ON MONDAY THAT WOULD BE
FANTASTIC SENATOR GONZALEZ WILL
BE PRESENTING A RESOLUTION ON
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE AND WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO JOIN
US. THANK YOU. MOVING MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MEMBERS THIS IS THE TIME FOR
THE ADJOURNING MEMORIES. LIKE
TO BEGIN WITH SENATOR STONE.
PRESIDENT AND AS YOU KNOW I
HAVE TO. FIRST I'D LIKE TO RISE
TODAY AN INTERN IN THE MEMORY
OF LARRY HOLDING THEIR TRIBAL
COUNCIL VICE CHAIRMAN AND
FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE AGUA
CALIENTE BAND OF CAHUILLA
INDIANS WHO. REGRETTABLY PASSED
AWAY ON JUNE JULY FIFTEENTH AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY YEARS OLD.
LARRY WAS BORN IN PALM SPRINGS
IN OCTOBER NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT BUT MOVED AS A CHILD WITH
HIS FAMILY LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTIES. HE LOVED
RACING AND BREEDING HORSES IN
HIS EARLY CAREER WAS SPENT
WORKING IN THE DEFENSE INDUSTRY.
BECAME INTERESTED IN TROUBLE
GOVERNMENT AS EARLY TWENTIES.
IN AN INTERVIEW YEARS LATER HE
SAID. I WAS DRAWN TO THE IDEA
THAT IF YOU DEDICATE YOURSELF.
YOU CAN MAKE A REAL POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE. AND LARRY CERTAINLY
DID JUST THAT HE DEDICATED
HIMSELF TO HIS TRIBE AN INMATE
A REAL DIFFERENCE FOR HIS
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. THIRTY BEGAN
HIS SERVICE ON THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE.
ANY HELD EVERY COUNCIL POSITION
INCLUDING CHAIRMAN WHICH YOU
SERVED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND HE
ALSO SERVED AS VICE CHAIRMAN IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE. HE WAS
VERY PROUD OF HIS NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE LARRY WAS A
RESPECTED LEADER WHO IS KNOWN
TO ASK THE TOUGH QUESTIONS TO
MAKE SRE WHAT WAS BEING
DEDICATED WAS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS. OF HIS TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. HE SERVED ON
NUMEROUS TRAVEL BOARDS AND WAS
THE FIRST CHAIRMAN OF THE ABA
KALI ANTI DEVELOPMENT
AUTHORITY. WHEN IT ESTABLISHED
ITSELF IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
HE AND OTHER LEADERS WERE PROUD
OF THE WORK THEY DID TO
ESTABLISH GAMING AS A TRIBAL
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE. HE ALSO
SERVED ON MANY BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS INCLUDING THE
NATIVE AMERICAN RIGHTS FUND.
THE GOVERNING BOARD FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COACHELLA
VALLEY MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
WHICH WORKS TO PROTECT THE
NATURAL AND CULTURAL RECESSES
OF THE BEAUTIFUL COACHELLA
VALLEY. HE WON SAID I CAN LOOK
BACK ON WHEN I WAS A COUNCIL
MEMBER NINETEEN SIXTY ONE AND
THANK. WE HAD A LITTLE BACK
THEN. WHAT EVOLVED AFTER THAT
WAS A RECOGNITION OF OUR
SOVEREIGNTY AND GAMING IT
CHANGED A TRY AND WHAT WE'RE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR OUR MEMBERS
NOW THE WAY THEY SHOULD BE
PROVIDED FOR AND THAT'S MADE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE. IN OUR
LIVES. LARRY LECHNER CHAINS
ALLIES AND IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THE AGUA
CALIENTE BAND AND ACROSS THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. HIS WIFE
SUSAN WILL SURELY MISS HER
BELOVED HUSBAND LERI OLINGER
WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A LEADER.
A LOVING HUSBAND. AND A FRIEND
TO ALL OF THOSE THAT HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING HIM THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO ADJOURN.
IN HIS MEMORY. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME TO THE DEATH SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED AND
IF YOU COULD EXPRESSED OUR
CONCERNS CONSIDER. THANK YOU
FOR HERBAL AND CONDOLENCES AND
ALSO LIKE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MISTER DON MIRABELLA.
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY YOU
PASSED AWAY ON JULY THE
SEVENTEENTH. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
DON BECAME A STATE AUDITOR THE
YOUNGEST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN HE WORKED AS THE
CONTROLLER FOR THE RIVERSIDE
MEDICAL CLINIC WHICH IS GROWN
TO BE ONE OF THE LARGEST IN OUR
COUNTY. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
HE MET HARY SUTHERLAND WHO WAS
SAFE WAYS EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HE STARTED WORKING WITH
SHELLY STREISAND BARBRA
STREISAND JACKIE ONASSIS AND
MANY OTHERS ENGAGED IN
CHARITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE HE
BECAME THE BUSINESS MANAGER FOR
THE SAME PORTANTINO MEDICAL
CLINIC. HE WAS A SUPPORTER OF
THE ARTS IN THIS COMMUNITY AND
HE SERVED ON SEVERAL BOARDS
INCLUDING THE LAGUNA COLLEGE OF
ART AND DESIGN. THE REMOTE A
BOWL. AND THE RIVERSIDE
PHILHARMONIC ORCHESTRA HE WAS
ALSO A PATRON OF THE SAN DIEGO
OPERA. THE OPERA PACIFIC
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY PACIFIC
SYMPHONY AND THE SENATE CENTRO
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND THE LOS
ANGELES BALLET. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETY FOUNDED WITH THIS
BEAUTIFUL WIFE Là CHIANA THE
PERFORMING ARTS GUILD ALLIANCE
AS A NON PROFIT TO BRING
CULTURAL AWARENESS TO LOCAL
SCHOOL CHILDREN. RIGHT IN THE
CENTER SEND ABOUT. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY DON WAS A FAMILY
MAN. HE SUPPORTED THE CATHOLIC
AT POLITICALLY IN THE RIVERSIDE
HE TOOK TIME OUT OF HIS BUSY
SCHEDULE TO COACHES CHILDREN
SOFTBALL AND SOCCER TEAMS. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS BEAUTIFUL
WIFE Là CHIANA THREE CHILDREN
MADELINE AND HER HUSBAND RICK
SCHAFFER VICTOR IN HIS WIFE
LISA MIRABELLA AND CHRISTIAN
AND HIS WIFE PATTY MIRABELLA IN
ADDITION. HIS FAMILY GREW TO
INCLUDE SIX GRANDCHILDREN AND
TWO GREAT GRANDSONS. MY FRIENDS
AND COLLEAGUES OF THE SENATE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TURN MEMORY OF
THIS GREAT COMMUNITY LEADER WHO
GAVE MUCH MORE THAN HE EVER
RECEIVED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
TO THE DEATH SO THAT HE CAN HE
CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. CENTER GALGIANI.
WILL PASS ON THAT SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO ASKED WE JOIN IN
MEMORY OF A LEGEND IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY HERO A VETERAN.
BUT SOMEBODY YOU WORK FOR SO
MANY OTHER VETERANS IN OUR
COMMUNITY CAPTAIN ARCHER
SHERMAN. CAPTAIN SHERMAN FLEW
WEST RECENTLY BUT. SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO HE FOUGHT FOR HIS
COUNTRY THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM AS
A B. TWENTY FOUR BOMBER DEAR AN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER IN WORLD
WAR TWO. AND HIS STORIES IN
LEGEND IN THE BETTER VETERAN
COMMUNITY IN OUR COUNTY ARE
EXTRAORDINARY. ANY JOKE THAT IN
FACT MOST OF THEM WERE IN FACT
TRUE. BUT OUR DID NOT JUST
SERVE OUR NATION. DECADES LATER
HE BROUGHT SOME CAMARADERIE
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY TOO OFTEN.
OUR VETERANS LEAVE THEIR WARS.
ISOLATION ESPECIALLY INTO THEIR
LATER YEARS IS DALY SPOUSES AND
GET SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES BUILDING SOME KIND OF
COMMUNITY IS NOT JUST
RECREATIONAL IT'S A LIFELINE
FOR THEM A REASON TO KEEP
LIVING AND SO HE PUT TOGETHER
SOME CALL WINGS OVER WENDY'S
THE LITTLE WENDY'S ON PLATT
RIGHT IN WOODLAND HILLS. AND
EVERY MONDAY MORNING SMALL
GROUP OF THEM GOT TOGETHER
WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS KOREAN
VIETNAM WAR VETERANS STARTED TO
COME ALONG AND NOW IT'S
EXPANDED SO THEY CAN'T EVEN
SQUEEZE INTO THAT LITTLE
WENDY'S ANYMORE. AND THEY'RE
NOT ON VENTURA BOULEVARD AND
THERE'S A WOMEN'S WITH WINGS
OVER WENDYS AND IT'S BECOME A
REAL PHENOMENON IN THE AREA AND
ARTS STARTED ALL. HE REFUSED TO
ACCEPT THE FATE THAT IS
COMPATRIOTS FACE LONELINESS IN
THEIR LATER YEARS AFTER BEING
HEROES TO US ALL. AND WHEN
MORNING MONDAY MORNING CAME WE
ALWAYS KNEW WE COULD COUNT ON
OUR FIRST SMILE. I WOULD BE
LOST ART BUT HIS MEMORY WILL
LIVE ON. FOR MANY YEARS AND
WE'RE VOWING TO CONTINUE HIS
WINGS OVER WENDYS LONG INTO THE
FUTURE HE SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTERS JUDY AND LINDA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE OFFER
OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY
LEGACY OF LEADERSHIP AND
SERVICE. AND INJURED IN HIS
MEMORY. THE CENTER SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY.
CENTER STREET STERN YOU HAVE
ANOTHER YEAH I DO THANK YOU FOR
THE INDULGENCE MEMBERS. CAL
PORTER. WAS A LEGEND IN THE
SURFING COMMUNITY A LIFEGUARD
TEACHER AND A LOVER THE PACIFIC
OCEAN. THIRTY SIX YEAR CAL
SERVED AS A LIFEGUARD FOR LA
CITY AND COUNTY STARTING HIS
CAREER JIM A BEACH A BELOVED
GENESIS OFF THE PACIFIC COAST
HIGHWAY IN MALIBU. HE GREW UP
IN VENICE AND MOVED TO MALIBU
IN THE FORTIES IN FACT HELP
START. LONGBOARDING MOVEMENT
SENSES BECOME A GLOBAL
PHENOMENON. BUT AT THAT
HISTORIC LITTLE WAVE HE MADE
HISTORY. HE LATER OPEN CAL
PORTERS MELBA SWIM SCHOOL IN
DAY CAMP WHERE HE TAUGHT LOCAL
KIDS HOW TO SWIM. HIS LOVE FOR
TEACHING BROUGHT HIM INTO A NEW
CAREER EARNINGS TEACHING
CREDENTIALS AND ACTUALLY A
MASTERS IN EDUCATION CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE. HE TRACKED ALL THE
WAY OFF TO THE VALLEY TO GET
THIS DEGREE. BEGAN A SECOND
CAREER AS AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER THEN AS A PRINCIPAL IN
FACT IN THE LAUSD SYSTEM. AFTER
HIS RETIREMENT FROM L. U. S. T.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY CAL MOVED TO
PARADISE CO WITH HIS WIFE ADELE.
AND HE BECAME A SURF HISTORIAN
AND A REGULAR CONTRIBUTOR TO
SURFER'S JOURNAL. AS WELL AS A
WATER QUALITY PATROL VOLUNTEER
FOR SANTA MONICA BAY KEEPER SO
HIS RETIREMENT WAS NOT THAT
RETIRED. CAL REMEMBERS A LOVING
FATHER AND HUSBAND AKON HAND IN
TIMES OF CONFLICT AND ROLE
MODELS SO MANY OF US WHO
REALIZE THAT BEING A SURFER AND
BEING A WATERMAN IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT A LIFESTYLE ABOUT
STEWARDSHIP IN CARING FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY RAISING UP THE NEXT
GENERATION HE IS SURVIVED BY
SON ALONG HIS DAUGHTERS KATHY
ANN FISHER NANCY RUSSELL NANCY
NGUYEN KATHY CARTER. HIS
GRANDCHILDREN SCOTT HARBIN
KELLY TANNER JULIE OLIVER AND
CAL IS GREAT GRANDDAUGHTERS.
THALIA CAROLINE ELEANOR AND AS
MAY YOU CAN SEE QUITE A LEGACY
LEFT HE WROTE HIS FIRST WAVE AT
THREE. AS LAST WAVE IN EIGHTY
EIGHT WE CAN ONLY HOPE TO LIVE
A LIFE IS FULL OF CAL DID SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RETURNING THIS
MEMORY. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
TO THE DEATH SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED
SENATOR GALGIANI. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I ASK
FOR THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF SYLVIA MARIE LOFTIS
FROM STOCKTON SHE WAS BORN ON
MARCH MARCH THIRD NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT IN SEATTLE
WASHINGTON WHILE RAISING HER
KIDS SHE WENT BACK TO SCHOOL
AND OBTAINED HER NURSING DEGREE
FROM SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE
AND HER BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS. SHE THEN
WORKED FOR APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AT SAINT JOSEPH'S
HOSPITAL AND A VARIETY OF
POSITIONS THE JURORS OF SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
NEW SYLVIA BECAUSE OF HER
FAMOUS LEMON BARS MANY JUDGES
OF THE COURT WE'RE LUCKY TO
HAVE SUCH A BIG FOR THEIR
JURIES. SHOULD ALWAYS REMEMBER
FOR HER DEVOTION TO HER FAMILY
AND FRIENDS SHE WAS SURROUNDED
BY OUR FAMILY IN THE LAST WEEKS
OF HER LIFE AND PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY ON AUGUST TENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. SHE IS VIPER
HAS BEEN ORDERED AND FOR
CHILDREN NINE GRANDCHILDREN AND
FIVE GREAT GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A TURNING IN HER
MEMORY THANK YOU. PLEASE BRING
HER NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT
SHE CAN BE APPROPRIATELY MEMORY
REALIZED SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS IT IS
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ROLE AND MARIA FLORES
IN THE TWENTY OTHER VICTIMS WHO
WERE KILLED ON AUGUST THIRD AND
ALL PASO TEXAS. IN THE SIXTY
YEARS THEY WERE MARRIED ROLL
AND MARIA REPRESENT AT THE
EPITOME OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
WELL THEY MADE IN THE CITY OF
THROUGH THAT HORACE MEXICO THE
CITY WHERE I WAS BORN. THEY
CHOSE TO CALL CALIFORNIA HOME
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THEIR LIVES
AS YOUNG ADULTS THEY RAISE
THEIR FAMILY AROUND THE HILLS
OF THIS ANKARA VALLEY. AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THEY RAISE
THREE CHILDREN ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN TEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND WE'RE WAITING
FOR ONE MORE ON THE WAY. ROLL
WORKED AS A PAINTER MOST OF HIS
LIFE AND WAS KNOWN AS HAVING A
STRONG WORK ETHIC IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY. MARIA
KNOWN AS A GRANDMA FLORES LOVE
TO COOK AND YOU EXACTLY WHAT
EVERYONE IN HER FAMILY LEFT TO
EAT. VISITING FAMILY MEMBERS.
WOULD FIND THEIR FAVORITE
DISHES WAITING FOR THEM. HAVING
RETIRED TO EL PASO THE FLORES
FAMILY WAS NOW SPLIT BETWEEN
TEXAS AND CALIFORNIA. ROLL WAS
SCHEDULED TO HAVE IT OPEN HEART
SURGERY ON AUGUST FIFTH. IN
ORDER TO BE WITH HIM MEMBERS OF
THE FAMILY JOIN HIM IN EL PASO.
ON THE DAY OF THE SHOOTING ROLL
AND MARIA WERE BUYING AIR BEDS
FOR VISITING RELATIVES. THEY'RE
DESCRIBED BY FAMILY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS INSEPARABLE THE ONLY
COMFORT THEIR RELATIVES TAKE IN
THEIR DATA IS THAT THEY WERE
TOGETHER UNTIL THE END. ROLL
AND MARIA WERE NEVER SEPARATED
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I SPENT TIME
AS A CHILD AND LIVED IN EL PASO
MY SISTER SO IT WAS BORN IN EL
PASO AND ALL MY FAMILY STILL
LIVES IN A PASSEL. SADLY MY
NIECE'S FRIEND WAS ONE OF THE
VICTIMS ON THAT TRAGIC DAY HIS
NAME IS LEO. COUPLES HE DIED
ALONG WITH HIS WIFE MARIBEL
HERNANDEZ THEY WERE MARRIED FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS. LEO WAS KNOWN AS
A HOPELESS ROMANTIC WHO
SURPRISES WIFE WITH FLOWERS.
AND HIS WIFE WAS NOWN FOR HER
UNWAVERING LOVE AND SUPPORT FOR
HER HUSBAND. I WILL YIELD THE
FLOOR THIS TIME TO THE GREAT
SENATOR OF LOS ANGELES IF I MAY
THANK YOU. SENATOR DRAWS A
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. A MAN
FEEL BY HATE AND RACISM RIPPED
BUT I WILL AND MY IDEA AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY. MEMBERS THE SHOOTING
IN EL PASO WAS NOT A SENSELESS
RANDOM ACT. IT WAS METICULOUSLY
PREMEDITATED FUELED AND ENABLED
BY PUBLIC RHETORIC. THE TARGETS
AND VILIFIED AS PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THIS INCIDENT IS A LONG IT IS
THE LATEST IN A LONG HISTORY OF
HATE CRIMES AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE LATINO COMMUNITY IN
THIS COUNTRY. IN THIS LIGHT I
ASK AS A UNIFIED BODY TO
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO COMBAT
ALL FORMS OF BIGOTRY AND HATE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. HATE CRIMES
AND VIOLENCE LIKE THE TYPE WE
SAW IN THE APOSTLE CANNOT
BECOME THE NEW NORM. THEY COULD
NOT BE. ACCEPTED OR EXPLAINED
AWAY. IN ADDITION TO THE
FAMILIES NAMED BY THE SENATOR
FROM BALDWIN PARK WE ALSO ASKED
TO ADJOURN FOR THE FOLLOWING
VICTIMS. JORDAN ON CHANDA
TWENTY FOUR AND ANDRE UNTIL
UNTIL TWENTY THREE. OUR DOODLES
BEN ABI THIS SIXTY JORGE
BELLEVILLE GARCIA SIXTY ONE.
OUR GOAL FOR SEVERAL IN LANDIS
SIXTY EIGHT AND SARAH ESTHER
LEGAL LEVEL SIXTY SIX. ANGELINA
AND PLEASE BE EIGHTY SIX.
ALEXANDER YOUR HARD HOFFMAN
SIXTY SIX. DAVID JOHNSON SIXTY
THREE. LOUISE WHAT IS NINETY MY
IDEA IS HANNYA LET OUR GUARD
Và FIFTY EIGHT. YVONNE
FILIBERTO MONTH SINAL. FORTY
ONE. GLORIA YOU'RE MY MARCUS
SIXTY ONE. L. SOME MENDOZA
FIFTY SEVEN. MARGIE RICARD
SIXTY THREE HI VIçT A MADE
RODRIGUEZ FIFTEEN. THAT IS A
SIGN JUST EIGHTY TWO AND ONE
THE VIOS VELASQUEZ SEVENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES OF ALL THE VICTIMS TO
THE DEATHS OF THE WEEK THEY CAN
BE APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH
A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TO
DATE. THAT AND ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A JAN
BLANK AND SHIP. SHE'S A DEAR
FRIEND. SHE IS AN EXAMPLE FOR
ALL OF US AN EXAMPLE IS A WIFE
A MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER. HERE'S
AN EXAMPLE OF A HELP MADE NO
PARTNER TO DON BLANKENSHIP HER
HUSBAND OF FIFTY THREE YEARS.
IT WAS BECAUSE OF JAN
BLANKENSHIP. AS A PARTNER THAT
DON COULD DEVOTE HIS LIFE TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SUPPORTING
THOSE IN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
JAN WAS THE KIND OF PERSON WHO
WAS ALWAYS UPBEAT SHE WAS THE
KIND OF PERSON WHO NEVER EVER
SAID A BAD WORD ABOUT ANYONE.
IT IS A LOSS TO OUR COMMUNITY
IS A LOSS TO OUR STATE IS A LOS
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
THAT JAN IS NOT WITH US. SO WE
GRIEVE WITH THE BLACK EDGE OF
FAMILY. AND WE PARTICULARLY
WANT TO RECOGNIZE HER SERVICE
NOT JUST ALL OF US BUT IN
PARTICULAR TO HER FAMILY SHE
WAS DEVOTED AS I MENTIONED TO
HER HUSBAND DON. BUT ALSO TO
OUR CHILDREN KERRY STACEY AND
DONNIE. AND SHE WAS. SUPREMELY
DEVOTED TO HER GRANDCHILDREN
JULIA MATALIN MASON AND LILY.
SO WITH THAT I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN ENGINE BLANK SHIPS
MEMORY THANK YOU. PLEASE BRING
HER NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT
SHE CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZE AND- CONVEY OUR
CONDOLENCES. MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES OUR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR WELLS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED AND WE'LL RECONVENE BACK
HERE IN THIS CHAMBER MONDAY AT
TWO PM HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL BE IN RECESS AT TWO AT
THREE THIRTY. AND WE WILL SEE
YOU ON MONDAY AT TWO O'CLOCK